welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by blue apron
blue apron is the leading meal kit
delivery service in the US and while
many people know what we do many don't
know what types of meal G when you cook
with blue apron
like I said blue apron is the number one
number one
fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the u.s. what we're going to
do is this blue aprons on the treat the
church what's happened now to their
first three meals a $30 value for your
first order if you visit blue apron coms
last Joey check out this week's menu and
get $30 off with free shipping at blue
apron comm slash Joey blue apron a
better way to cook number two on it you
know I'm down I'm all-in what's the name
of the stuff they take to remember [ __ ]
alpha brain alpha brain never [ __ ]
fails me understand me I'm a [ __ ]
Savage money-back guarantee if you don't
like it and you don't even want the
[ __ ] product back this is what I'm
talking about
people who stand behind that product
that's why I deal with on it number two
if you're a fat [ __ ] or a little on the
big side and you're thinking about
joining jiu-jitsu you want a nice gay
listen Fugees been there for me last
week I was rolling around there's
something I'm big I ripped me but I
thought it was the key it was the
[ __ ] patch hear it that's how tough
[ __ ] Fuji is in this Tami Fuji ELLs
on the patch fell apart
[ __ ] the patch go with the gay [ __ ]
Fuji sports.com slash Church kick that
[ __ ] melee the Church of what's
happened now you bad [ __ ]
everybody wants some how you guys doing
uncle Joey here my favorite uncle Nick
the Toro and my favorite [ __ ] Jew
killer the one and only Lisa ad you got
three more days left Lee there you could
drop the guilt after the seventh year
off the hook that's when the [ __ ]
three [ __ ] people show up from Poland
hidden that the three were pre show up
what I'm gonna [ __ ] they were the three
wise men
whenever Wiseman they came from Russia
with a Korean listen bro number one I
want to apologize to you
make the tour I got this big [ __ ]
well you wanna give me some volume over
there I have this big [ __ ] problem
next tutorial and I hope you don't get
disrespected by this I don't give a [ __ ]
what a person does with that kids if you
want to come over to my house when I'm
smoking pot with your kid you better
know number one I'm not stopping the pot
because your kids there you brought them
into my home [ __ ] turf you should
have known better number two I don't
care if you show up here with your kid
it's other kids that make me nervous
because they don't know me they get a
little high they think I'm gonna get
high with none next thing you know they
[ __ ] fall down they tell the mother
they will uncle Joey and I got handcuffs
on KTLA for child molestation or
forgiving some [ __ ] kid refund
forgive me one kid won the [ __ ]
challenge you he's a [ __ ] no that's
what I fly no that's what I didn't know
I'm anti all that she can I tell you the
guys this the owner if the [ __ ] kids
he could hang with you up the kids
father calls me next time I miss is my
foot my son's going down and I hang out
with you if he dies it's on his own I
know then we could bunk I know these
kids but they're good kids
I understand but Nick you know the way
it is no I know these kids aren't us
they're sensitive only listen I know
adults that have gotten up and ran out
of here you understand me I know adults
that have got luck the problem I hang
out with a lot of these kids so I can I
forget that's it because I'm one of the
adult can hangs with all your problems
no that's what keeps me young
Nick another why you know it's personal
I'm a criminal I you don't want these
kids around I know I could be doing Tony
all right you're right one of these kids
each one of these takes one of these
stars when I'm in the bathroom he goes
home he sees a devil
listen yeah Lee how many people have sat
in this Jade in a storm we've seen them
lay the couch
leave one guy walked around the back the
Penrose you're right oh you're not wrong
no I was gonna call you I should've
called I am I am deepest apologies you
don't worry you give you a kid
permission to come into the Voodoo
Lounge and I shoot heroin he's gotta
watch it some chick comes in here blows
my pipe he's gotta watch it he said I
was a [ __ ] kid my godfather would
pick me
Sunday even though I beat him later on
for drugs and he wanted to shoot me and
[ __ ] my godfather
he introduced me to it when I was really
young
five four that I really needed a man in
my life he would take me on Saturdays to
42nd Street would eat something
somewhere like a burger you know I was a
little [ __ ] Punk
we wanted a hamburger or a hot dog
because I was trying to be an American
oh he would say that's gonna make this
cafe in the late sixties Victor's
respected you wanted to Victor's you
bumped into Kennedy his [ __ ] with some
Cuban chick you know but [ __ ] uh not
all of the hamburger and he would get
kind of pissed up on while we were well
I was eating the burger he'd be sitting
there in 1965 68 already rolling the
joint at the table and while we would
walk he'd smoked a joint he told me this
is marijuana
don't smoke when you get older and don't
tell nobody you said that you saw me
smoking yeah and I would see what it'd
do to him and then afterward he would
take me by one of his girlfriends I was
like I knew his wife and [ __ ]
I know his kids I know everybody he
didn't give a [ __ ]
he'd take me to one of his [ __ ] house
and he make him come on he'd he'd tell
like share his tits yeah I was like five
I'd be like [ __ ] petrified Godfather
he's the one that put the water on my
[ __ ] head with my father he grew up
with my real [ __ ] father this is your
Godfather
this was my godfather and he loved me
and I loved him he look like Dick Van
Dyke he had the same head though oh [ __ ]
and he would take me to his girlfriend's
house and he would always roll joints on
bamboo and lick the [ __ ] joint and
he'd get Jaime giggle Nick the way we
giggle like here I go and I go someday
I'm gonna get all muffins smoking giggle
like him because he would just have a
good time no alcohol no nothing Emily
she took me to see like every Saturday
we went to see our Majesty Secret
Service that was the only James Bond
without a Jamie month I'll never forget
that I got skis after that he took me to
get skis and I would set up skis in my
bedroom and my mom
when they don't I'm scared I said the
blankets up and [ __ ] but then Dirty
Harry camera he took me to the Valachi
paper when I was a kid I went going to
the movie ya gonna every Saturday at 1
o'clock a line where the matinee on 42nd
Street okay Noll and I didn't know the
language Nick
every [ __ ] sadly like clockwork he
was knocked on my door at 9:00 take it
to the movies dressed me up you know
getting me ready brushed my teeth called
my hair talked to my mom for a little
while and he [ __ ] boogie and he
wouldn't have to have me back though
eight o'clock at my old are you five six
Wow this had to be before my mom met my
stepfather so I was when I was six so I
never forget he took me to see Dirty
Harry though in the theater and the
theater and when we left there were
eating and he goes put your hand up what
are you talking about he was a la mano
well know how I might mess up a lot
money Puma wha-wha-wha
I thought it generally give me cash he
put a gun in man and I looked at there
was the same gun Dirty Harry had a
Magnum the three the whole [ __ ] gun
I'm [ __ ] five in a movie did and I'm
in a [ __ ] restaurant in New York when
I'm holding on to a gun like I think
he's the greatest man in the world it's
loaded right whatever yeah it could have
been loaded I don't know I was I wasn't
gonna touch it I just said he put it on
my hand like this I just looked at him
wow
and then he started telling that's the
most powerful weapon in the world the
blow man's head off that's the same gun
in the movie and [ __ ] you take the same
line and I gave him the gun back and it
was true like that type of [ __ ] but he
was my godfather
it was his [ __ ] decision dude I'm
saying yeah I would never he would never
say to me bring your buddies because he
knew what type of trouble I was in again
right that's a different world the thing
is I got keep teenage people kids you
know in this alone I don't have forties
and parties and all these kids call me
big man big man big nameless no they all
they all hang with me it's funny I
almost got like an idea for a show or a
guy that hangs out with all these kind
of kids so it's kind of like endearing
so you know I forget I forget if I you
know
you know I love this respect know what
you owe them now apologize to them now
don't get oh and they get all worried
about dads call me than their but I
listen you listen if you're a young kid
you want to come over here show up with
a slip with your dad's signature and his
phone number and we'll call him while
your stacks time we'll do the paper and
I want his number to come up on the
[ __ ] caller ID or this ain't happen
I'm just lucky nothing's happened you
know I've had a lot of parties kids do
what they do I take the charge or
compile no I mean you know I try to be
careful thank God not going what nothing
happen because these kids that I'm
responsible you know so I'm not trying
to be negligent like our dreams I got
dreams and it'll include comedy and then
I'll include [ __ ] films I am video
life
because I would love to have a clean
police record so I could coach a girls
basketball team from six to eight that's
where I would take a girl and that's
when their [ __ ] up a little bit that
dad's ain't around you coach your girl
you treat them the right way that's set
for [ __ ] life you're the coach for
life yeah they'll come back and see you
every [ __ ] year or the other dream
might have is to start a program for
kids where every dead different parent
has to come out of the house and they
close off the street like we grew up in
New York and it's Monday to Friday block
parties and the kids could come out and
there's a football basketball a wiffle
ball and you have to do everything yeah
but are you not in that [ __ ] house
Nick I know but there's this that
wouldn't work it doesn't exist as an
existing that's a dream for me because
we used to play pole to pole my mother
was on the porch
Tommy Emily's mother was down the block
Louie alvarius mother was on the other
quadrants name and names and a span of
like two three blocks everything
happened and your mother if she wanted
you she just called from the porch and
it was a beautiful work world you know I
mean I just the way I grew up it was
like we weren't rich with money but we
were rich with so many other things like
my brother Dan had the same experience
about the neighborhood I grew up in so
he's like well you like that
neighborhood you liked he was always
autistic and I think he always thought
he was better than that neighborhood but
it was a beautiful place I mean when I
go back I it's gone I feel sad I went by
them
you know you feel sad because you
remembered the world that was here there
was a world death now it looks smaller
it looks different it looks like wow
everybody's gone like the twilight zone
and I remembered our world but it's gone
and you're my tears
before this again no disrespect to you
were talking about his son when we're
talking about that you know he went to
Chicago he gave a semester and again and
Nicki's a great kid I know that poor kid
since he was five I love you
he's a [ __ ] tremendous kid he's got
tons of talent he does his own me Rach
you know I think I follow him on Twitter
then I'm gonna be janked with ya so uh
bye handsome neck and this goes back to
what I'm [ __ ] telling you like my
friend right now who I love dearly has
got a kid and a little men somewhat but
they got heavy looting yeah so they put
him away at some school with six people
in a class and they pay a lot of loot
and the kick comes home and now they
want to send them to some weird City and
I sit there at night thinking about wait
a second this kid the most excitement
he's ever seen in his life is Laurel
Canyon you know if you stand in the
corner in Laurel can see those cars go
back and forth that's action to him well
that's everything the action yeah I'm
not trying to be sarcastic I'm [ __ ]
and realistic yet so how you gonna put
that can in your fanny
how long till socially in the pressures
of that city those cars doing nine
because I'm 55 and I grew up there and I
go back to the do comedy and I don't
like standing on the corner like I got
anxiety my heart starts beating I can't
[ __ ] breathe I live here now right
this is the lifestyle right now I get
you but how can you grow up being in
Chicago I know you grew up with three
black kids here and their names are
[ __ ] you know 21 year old kid which
he could be you know that's not right
why isn't it when an 18 year old it's
kid Rob's him and that was the whole
issue and then the kid wouldn't admit it
he had they had the proof and I'm like
at least just say yeah I stole the $50
or whatever and we can move on
and so that was bad enough the guys
robbing from him
and you know it's the Midwest it's
Chicago's a nice city but it's also very
but the kids are flying in
they come from a kept society you know
Lee do you remember a time when kids
play on the street and using your youth
it's a messed up cuz of my I grew up on
I like a busier Street kind that but not
really it's my good week I grew up one -
well I can't [ __ ] you believe I was on
205 West 88th Street it don't get no
busier than I remember your address give
me your address say th true 43 - Oh 600
32nd Avenue okay Rosedale New York PS
160 [ __ ] 60s 38 and that's a
car okay so those names all that [ __ ] I
remember okay something about remembers
I forgot at my street I've had my mother
coming up to me have your phone number
your home phone number
no still MLA 8/3 703 what a number steal
your identity like oh [ __ ] I shouldn't
have said that
that's right well I'll medieval all
right that's fake don't middle like I
think about how yeah how can I be in
this how can these kids be prepared to
be put in a big city where the most
action they've seen is Ventura Boulevard
it's not fair no you're right you're
right I mean he you know he knows New
York but I think Chicago felt a little
weird to him like when I left I I had a
weird feeling in my stomach like I don't
know if this is gonna work I'm just no
but he has to take a shot listen that's
the most trying [ __ ] thing and that's
not the worst thing I have a friend
that's flipping out right now the wife
is flipping out and he's told her he's
like thank God I dropped out of college
I wouldn't have all this he's not
dropping out he just don't want to go to
school no he goes I went for two
semesters that time and I got a job in
Hollywood and now I'm a [ __ ] ride and
that's how we live up in the canyons
with a button named [ __ ] Jojo I'm
saying man you know we got a [ __ ]
lady who lives next door to wipe the
kids ass I mean these people filthy
[ __ ] rich Wow
and the wife the wife gets pissed
whatever [ __ ] we're talking about Wow
you know in women are women I mean you
know oh no it's the one about the kid
I'm sorry
Oh Mikey no not you all this other kid
Newt kid what the kid came back
and he's like one if I didn't have these
issues I wouldn't have been here but
that we've spent all them and they went
for [ __ ] a lot they bought the car
and had it transported ah the building
they got they got they got the cabbage
right oh yeah this is just a bad day for
them it's like a bank it's not like you
know ya know then nobody lost these
schools are a lot of money partying in
it you don't think you're getting
something out of it even the school
didn't even say well why are you leaving
my brother even said did they say why
are you gonna go No so that's a bad sign
they should say well you know don't give
it a little more time or you try to
convince you that shows you right there
people go to this school they leave left
and right their turnover is bad he said
that cash poor so maybe just was a bad
fit you know he wanted it to work out I
mean you know this [ __ ] school down
the corner here Valley College tip-top
Magoo nobody gets their feelings hurt
they still miss spaghetti and always you
go two years you do good now you save
money if you actually want to do with
your life think about all the
aggravation that you were the [ __ ] say
that you would stay at home with your
mother me oh you still got your dick
sucked in the basement by the garbage
can
nobody's I think on a [ __ ]
aggravation of millions you could have
put away if you just want to stay and
shut your [ __ ] mouth you could've
shot my pretty blue and flown home and
live with Grandma Kidman go to church on
Sundays and still get your little
stomach get something confessional and
nobody knows nothing in those days
nobody's gonna come at you with a tape
from 1984 and say we hate your ass and a
[ __ ] bingo hall you know it's pretty
tough to hide a cat with a big dog we
just done that man that got married the
first time forget it Jesus Christ if we
were late morning yeah I want you all
day five minutes if you just stayed in
the [ __ ] basement and socked away
your millions you dumb [ __ ] doing it I
think
was alive I'd be in that [ __ ]
basement with a Playboy bunny picture up
jerking off I wouldn't even look at a
woman you understand me
I'd be living there off Mama's bosom
getting AK getting those good Cuban food
with some fried bananas I would not
leave that [ __ ] house sad clothes
listen free rang when I was 21 i
poisoned my father just her principle
just to take over Laos now I'm saying
like if I was a normal kid from a normal
house and I had one of those moms that
baked this [ __ ] your English I rub your
feet and [ __ ] when you got home and
called you Sonny Boy do you want me to
bring you up to me I would have poison
my father you know saying I was I got
really old man and taken over this [ __ ]
let the pension take care of the
mortgage let the life insurance take
care of the mortgage every thought
that's out Joey no but this is what I
would do if I was a normal white kid
myself with all this [ __ ] life just
poison your father and taking over the
house he's got a pension he's got
everything prepared all these white
people you know we've got everything in
case he leaves
god forbid bull they show you where it
is both of my parents are taking me and
show me where their stuff is what stuff
all their stuff whenever when it happens
they take you soon as they turned 50
they start telling you where they like
the Wills and tell me where this in case
I got some people up there who just tie
your mother up and take the loot it's no
it worries me bro I sit here and I go
what am i doing my daughter I'm gonna
raise the studio sit here right great
well she's gonna be a Harvey victim no
problem it's either Harvey or listen
there's always a Jew to replace you you
know sayin
how old is she she's fine but I see
pictures of her you know and it's it's
so funny this because I've never seen
you in person with her but it's adorable
just to see that little girl with you
she says you know I just like to think
of you with a little girl five years it
doesn't even like I can't compute in my
head you know like Joey Coco walking
a five-year-old girl but it's it's the
best when you know it easy is let me
tell you you got a few years yet before
she starts to get a little complicated
please she's five and she already like
tonight she don't want to kiss there was
some problem playing oh I like [ __ ]
put a gun to a like listen you don't
[ __ ] kiss me there's no skateboard on
your birthday then she kissed me she was
I'm gonna miss you in your gun she knows
how to work it yeah oh she does they
work any affair early they figured out
she puts her against my mom and my wife
yeah oh yeah she knows how that [ __ ]
doubletrack my wife and go on has daddy
oh daddy said it was alright then she'll
come in and look at me like frozen and
then the other day something happened I
had her at the park it was just me at
her something happened and she threw a
little Puerto Rican fit at me and had it
grab it by the handle listen you know me
and my mom will leave right the [ __ ] now
and she calmed down and I gave it a
tissue and when my wife pulled up an
hour later as my wife was park and she
looked at me she was that don't tell mom
I threw a fit okay she said no oh yeah
yes she knows she knows she's smart huh
yes
yeah but she knows how to play ball to
you yeah if you're ready for that daddy
but yeah I heard her I was in my office
I heard that sound my wife mommy I'm
gonna sleep with you tell that daddy
said it was okay if I slept with you
tonight
she asked me if she could sleep at me
and I said listen do you sleep with us
maybe like this weekend that's what I
said she was working my wine my wife
came in and ass but I said no I said
tell her what I told you you said I
think when it's of tonight of this
weekend I said no no this weekend
nothing above charts asleep in the bed
yeah so we give away one night a week
like Sunday's his family a night and
it's a [ __ ] nightmare
it's a [ __ ] nightmare I sleep in a
foot and my kidney on that I wake it's
only one night one night a week she
sleeps it my daughter was good yeah my
son was a nightmare that guy would make
sneak attacks for years that's why I
said he didn't grow so [ __ ]
guy never slept came in every night for
years I see a silhouette jump out of bed
and there he was sneaking in I try to
make a [ __ ] move on the land on her
and then my arm it's him in the middle I
couldn't get him out of my bed for many
many years there's a problem this
[ __ ] guy took over my bed took he
took her I felt like you know I felt
like that yeah even today he's still
jumping in the [ __ ] bad teasing me I
dragged him out of the [ __ ] bed he's
always getting under my skin you know he
likes the bottom we're close but just
know he's relentless and you know what
bro but he loves his mother I'm happy
he's home because that's a nightmare for
me I don't even like my cat out of the
house like if my cat was one of those
cats that you have let out at night yeah
I can't sleep at night every night I was
always a little worried yeah listen I'm
the type of dude if I like you and you
look close to me I don't tell you this
but every night in the drive home I
Drive by your house I Drive by Lee's
house every night
you don't know it I either drive down
that side street when I go smoke a joint
or I hate to drive back on Laurel King
and then make a right on your corner and
come home without that's the type of guy
yeah they're saying you always checked
yeah of course all people so I mean you
don't want to get a call one day you
know it's bad enough anything could
happen and I can't [ __ ] imagine my
child I notice like me living here being
[ __ ] 70 helloween and mercy living in
New York fighting for [ __ ] life me
thinking about the career thing that
[ __ ] button that's bad nothing
thinking about that Korean hitting the
button if you go to New York and I said
it before and I grew up there I Love New
York with all my heart but let me tell
you something go to New York and you
just you could smell bomb you can smell
bomb you could just it's inevitable
they're not gonna stop till they take
down that [ __ ] city they're not gonna
stop and they're building on top of
people they build a New Jersey no not
Edgewater they're [ __ ] that they're
putting building I love it but it looks
like you know so that's all that [ __ ]
get I can't sleep at night just thinking
that'd be like rre my friend Ari
in New York if I get up in the middle of
night I always call cuz it's 5:00 in the
morning and [ __ ] New York I'm lunges
here cuz he's one of those nights that
city is just it's a target you look at
it you always say your rights is even
though you've been after the Trade
Center it's just looming like you know
it could happen again someday something
could have I still remember being in the
city at the time they hit the first the
first time they hit the World Trade
Center I was on like Broadway and I was
delivering packages for a phone company
I mean the first bombing the first
bombing in 93 94 I never had a pager in
those days the guy would my job was from
1 to 5
I'd give 400 a week and I had a certain
coverage every day and I had a drop off
packages in that coverage but I drop all
six packages and all they sometimes they
drove me up to the [ __ ] place and
when I do is run upstairs on the [ __ ]
elevator sign the thing and drop off the
package it was some type of phone
messaging service they got bought by
Sprint - something years later they were
on them they were out of Virginia there
would be I have forget what the [ __ ]
they're worn out and they were giving me
400 a week just a drop or packages every
[ __ ] day down on lower you know all
around and I had a pager and for some
reason the pages stopped working because
somebody told me they were gonna call me
an hour and this person always called me
and I [ __ ] said [ __ ] I'm not gonna
weigh this city all afternoon for them
to call me back I guess I'm done for the
day and I took the [ __ ] bus over and
I knew the World Trade Center had been
hit but I guess they hit the tower so
there was no reception for a bunch of
people I didn't know this [ __ ] later
bang that that's why my page they had
been paging me I just wasn't getting no
pages because they had knocked down some
signal yeah I still remember that I
still never be in the city that [ __ ]
day so I wouldn't happen the second time
I was in [ __ ] Schrader I was in
Hollywood Boulevard you know I was in
the Jersey Shore and my friend called me
and he said I was gonna fly that week -
ironically he knows tutorial you were
you home I yeah that's why I turned the
TV on your we're at war some [ __ ] that's
a war and a bad fight - at home the
night before and a bad drag down
I don't was nothing over some stupid
[ __ ] and then it turned the TV on look
like a little toy it was coming right
through I didn't know what the [ __ ] I
was looking at you know in the plane
that went right through the second
you're just surreal [ __ ] surreal and
then I think about a week later a week
or two later I drove back cross-country
I [ __ ] drove back I got mistaken
I got mistaken a Walmart for a terrorist
one time to me means get Gabe like
Filipino concept all right after that
crazy white one for two months I read
she goes it was like what the [ __ ] I
wish was a warm white employee cuz I
said I could sue Walmart they were
accusing me of being a terrorist on the
drive back yeah and the drive back I
stopped like in Kansas and stopped in
all these places I went to baseball
stadiums I was driving a [ __ ] Toyota
Sequoia and I was pulling a [ __ ]
little u-haul and said you could go
about 45 mile an hour with the u-haul I
was doing about 90 [ __ ] you all I
pull into these baseball stadiums right
and the problem was parking the
[ __ ]
yeah was attached to the it's attached
to the car where do you usually leave
the you want the hole I was carrying
stuff back from Jersey and they u-haul
and and and so I pull in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] they don't have to attach to you
all and put to you all in one spot in
the Sequoia and another you know one
time man yeah whatever then Baltimoreans
told me it's very ugly you I said what
what do you want me to do and he go your
pocket somewhere else so you can't be
driving at you all looking the way you
do two weeks after 9/11 I was a [ __ ]
me that is the funniest [ __ ] funny as
[ __ ] what time do you old I you know I
disconnected it it started [ __ ] going
down in Kansas City it started like
going down the road I was grabbing it
almost through it waited a lot of weight
I'm heavy though yes [ __ ] heavy oh it
was hysterical I mean all only a guy
like me would be driving across country
with a u-haul at Toyota Sequoia and
stopping at major league baseball
stopping in Kansas City and stopped in
in Camden Yards I stopped in Coors Field
they stopped where else did I stop
Pittsburgh you know I was doing my space
fall tour for just the thoughts of
ladybug yeah did they stop field days
no no it was the woman who said she was
a customer she was looking at my game
was Filipino and me one talk so I can be
mistaken for an Iranian at times or any
day we were [ __ ] those game is like
[ __ ] Forrest Gump that's my
right-hand man terrorists I was like
Gabe stop it he's like the [ __ ] Rain
Man
Gabe is like the [ __ ] hi a highly
functioning you know all right
idiot savant he's [ __ ] hilarious man
just trying to express myself
[ __ ] great Gabe you're like he
watches me watching the Yankee game so
he's a co-op friend so now like when he
watches the Seahawk game do you think
like me like watching the Yankee games
cuz he likes to curse now cuz he feels
like you know he can express himself
better that I listen I love Lisa at he's
my brother I love did that I love
breaking his balls you know and we're in
Vegas you know in life you go out and
like I have five friends
well I hung out like well I was 19 let's
pretend 1982 at Pelican stinky me and
[ __ ] Bernie that was the four of us I
knew each of our limitations and I know
who was capable of doing who and what at
any minute
you know stinky was the type of guy that
he loved everything we did but he didn't
want to hold anything so you know what
he'd pay you for the coke but he didn't
want to hold it he was just one of those
dudes I'd rather not hold it right
Bernie on the other hand would strap a
[ __ ] donkey on to him and walk across
the border
like nothing happened you know that uh
and and and the other [ __ ] lunatic
he'd do anything like he was just crazy
so when when things happen when those
guys are around nothing surprises you do
you know this thing you know those cruel
people you grew up with right thank you
really no no I really got to know Lee
and I just sweetheart of a guy and we're
in Las Vegas right and the star guy
comes right the guy you know and he
shows up and we're having a good time
it's after a show in Vegas
it's gotta be 400 people 200 people
leave and there's actually 200 people
standing around and we're just talking
but there's 10 bags of those things
going around and people are just [ __ ]
eating them in the hallway of this hotel
in [ __ ] Las Vegas like it's popcorn
and a movie theater and I'm looking at
this scene going holy [ __ ] this is
hysterical and the next thing you know I
see a security guard run up and he's
just like pointedly and and I'm like and
I'm talking to people I'm trying to be
nice I just can't leave the people I'm
trying to pay attention to the people at
the same time see what's going on with
me and the next thing you know he's
almost gonna get arrested because the
camera saw him giving somebody a stop so
they escorted into his room took his
[ __ ] made him get dressed and their
squad room at home all right the [ __ ]
criminal whatever they whatever they
made him get undressed whatever the [ __ ]
but he's banned from the hotel for life
listen I understand you tell we can't
come back for six months but really
banned for life I mean it's medical
marijuana if you really took a look at
it was it legal yeah who cares you got
guys over here trying to rob your hotel
dude I'm saying right you have to expect
this holtam that when you go to the
palms
you smell weed in the hotel at the pox
if you check into the palms of your kids
and you call downstairs and go excuse me
I don't know what to do it's a horror
show up
this is the palms yeah yeah I got a
stripper saying daddy don't [ __ ] me in
the ass make the daughter mean huh I got
people in the hallway snorting cocaine
and and I got people like score playing
a guitar you know when you're at the
Palms bro it's a hotel for kids of the
21 through 25 26 take over the club and
then they pop ecstasy and they're right
in the [ __ ] hotel there's a section
there for young kids where they jump up
and down I'll know if it's the proms
anymore but fear I was told the story
the other day that one time there was
gonna be a UFC fight there this had to
be before I was even married before I
was even with Terry I used to go to this
place dukes for breakfast every day
that's how I got to be 418 pounds I
would snort coke at night and gonna do
it for breakfast on the Sunset Strip and
I go to everyday and get a [ __ ]
three-egg omelet with American cheese of
extra American cheese and steak fries
for breakfast and a side order of bacon
and coca-cola Jack nothing but you bring
that diet over here by mistake there
would be a [ __ ] beat in here and if
you look to the count you know what
Dukes is I've heard well the Sunset
Strip and next to that rock bar the reel
for the whiskey yeah yeah but I wish you
ain't and if you go in there I was going
there for [ __ ] days a week and this
is after I would eat breakfast at my
where I was living or these are the days
when I used to eat when I was living go
to McDonald's and get an Egg McMuffin
and with the hash brown and drink the
soda and I would go to my buddy's house
smoke dope then we go over there like at
9:45 10:00 o'clock and I get the cheese
on but that was my third breakfast oh my
with the steak fries and I look over to
the side and there's your boy he would
be in there four days a week hanging out
with a beard
talking to people at the counter [ __ ]
John help Wilk with the what's his name
John wick um he would be there he would
be in that part okay four nights four
days then and [ __ ] nicer than [ __ ]
[ __ ] till this day I think about that
like no jesus [ __ ] christ and I never
said
toom - like after about a year I finally
said hello to him was something on the
way I one day he had a newspaper and I
was sitting on the counter I was there
by myself I didn't have to say hello but
I said it you know I'm saying yeah I
didn't take a picture of him I didn't
bother the poor guy he had a beard long
your hair you didn't leave bro when you
see him in the daytime you know little
ain't no [ __ ] Hollywood model he's
just a regular guy you know Sam right so
I saw him I had nothing but I saw him
that much time but there was a waitress
there they used to work that wish which
you wouldn't Miss America contest
not really but she had nice body and she
was a sweet girl she was very nice and I
always thought that she was a little
over flirtatious that was my breakfast
place of choice so I never really said
that into her I'd smile and leave a nice
tip and leave well this particular night
I go to the prom so we're ogling those
dudes and dog I'm not doing blow I'm
doing blow but I have some upstairs in
the room and for some reason I just
wasn't the mood to do it ro give those
guys Eddie Bravo wanna go to a bar
but I'm the walk to the bar and the
palms were all those people walking in
the hallways you know how they [ __ ]
thousands of people I saw the waitress
from Dukes that I believe in breakfast
that for a year that's kind of [ __ ]
cute I never really said nothing to I
always knew she could have been a freak
this confirmed it but there were so many
people Nick that we got the seats on the
last moment and hit each other's hand
and she said are you staying here and I
go yeah I'll see you later then we kept
walking like that's [ __ ] weird I went
up to my room bro took a shower got her
and went to bed well I woke up went to
bed like at 10:30 hmm I woke up like at
4:15 in the morning I'm [ __ ] starving
you know right I said [ __ ] it let me
walk downstairs I walk downstairs bro
and there was like a [ __ ] pick em you
know cuz you would I would say sat there
breakfast neck and there was a check by
herself drinking champagne and as soon
as she saw me she toasted the glass to
me and I was like holy [ __ ] that's a
hook I am I know look I don't know that
I don't know what's going on problem
next thing you know some other chick
came in and started talking to a bunch
of guys next thing on another drunk
chick came in with a shoe bust it
started talking no no that she came up
and sat at the table neck oh it started
talking to me didn't we get some coke
honey and this [ __ ] was banging and I
was like I don't know nothing and next
thing you know guess who walks in oh the
waitress from [ __ ] Dukes and she sees
me she can run her with the table we
start talking I answer she when she's a
little [ __ ] up I get down I said she
wants to get high absolutely don't for
the room we finish off the dude salutes
and then why I eat a monkey that's it
two weeks later I got a table from her
yeah why an omelet that she was the
waitress said darling
[ __ ] phrases this had to be 20
[ __ ] years ago
Wow 19 years ago was that a good memory
boy what was the point of the [ __ ]
story anyway I don't know there was a
point there was there was a point [ __ ]
it's so lost lately you know for
momentum I don't know is the age I can't
remember from moment to moment no I just
said walk around take a [ __ ] you wipe
your ass you get up really what did I do
I forget I had my hand I forget this I
forget that it's just my [ __ ] brain
is just not sharp
do you not write anything that I gotta
start right I'm starting to write [ __ ]
down because I'm gonna have violet
saying yeah thing an alpha brain and
maybe need to smoke a little pot to get
the [ __ ] mental go and I'm really
smoke weed but it's a bomb
get them get them good [ __ ] I have some
medical [ __ ] but they give to you before
they take an eye yeah before they kill
you that they listen you leave your eyes
to let's say on the back of your license
you say I want to leave I leave you I
leave your eyes are years or something
listen if your three quarters have you
alive be the moment I saw this real
sports [ __ ] kid sky left go don't
kill you alive when you won't because
they'll take your eyeball let's say you
don't wish the eyeballs are in the black
market eight thousand like right now
there's something go listen he's blind
he's like listen I want some nice Jew
eyes I got a [ __ ] implant anyway I
got one implant so listen what was I
ever do with the Jew I I don't know
someone who wants an eye right in the
[ __ ] Arabia somewhere he he wants two
eyes and some point Jews driving down
the street and [ __ ] sunset and he
gets his eyes widened and nice in the
hospital he's a half-ish mom you a
doughnut no cuz I'm scared cuz if I'd
say if you're a half of Momo and you got
three quarters left her life and they
can't find your wallet or your phone for
you to call your loved one don't just
look around and go hit them in the head
and somebody comes over and puts a hand
over your mouth like Clemenza really oh
[ __ ] yeah and they take guys know what
they do you know there's a blood
do not go your eyes no way he just got
him [ __ ] federal they are nice yeah
they do we eyes within it hey wait till
you die [ __ ] now who want someone to die
never see that episode of Law & Order
when the guy just said stab him no like
there's an episode about Law & Order
pretty interesting and they had a case
on him and that they were losing the
case so the [ __ ] DEA said dig deeper
and finally some chick said I've got a
confession to make I went them for an
abortion and when the baby came out it
was still alive and he asked me what he
wanted to do when I told him to
terminate him and he basically he turned
around and snapped his [ __ ] neck so
this connect him to this other crime
that he did or the [ __ ] throws from
either they don't have but they do and
they base it off real stories Lee they
just changed the names yeah but they
used the story and the no no no no so
what this good doctor did was he already
had ordered the anesthesia for the
[ __ ] patient at a certain time he had
to go to the pharmacy and take the
anesthesia
he lied so they asked him why would you
have the anesthesia if they weren't dead
they got him that way went through
something he checked out came back to
kick him in the ass which proves that
[ __ ] it
he had a deal with a clinic that needed
eyeballs quick so if he delivered the
eyeballs quickly he got a bonus oh
really
yeah so that's why he [ __ ] with just
that people was he bought originally he
married on Hayes he's run away he loses
his mother stabbed yeah and they stab
you next to you boys oh he got hit by a
car then he was laying there some Isis
came and stabbed the man I saw a BB ran
away yeah you are thinking somebody
stabbed you and next thing that your
mom's touching your face and she goes to
open up the eyeball and there's [ __ ]
the back of your skull and she goes I've
been through his eyes well we took those
are these are done it he's checked the
box geez that's how [ __ ] quick don't
you remember he is on 60 minutes they
did a thing about we
who would [ __ ] lawyer in Las Vegas and
they would take it to a hotel room and
you would be [ __ ] on the next thing
you know you wake up in a tub filled
with ice and ever even note on you to
call hotel security get an ambulance
that they took your kidneys took your
kidneys dog they would [ __ ] any dope you
and while you were [ __ ] sleeping they
would take your [ __ ] kidney a kidneys
one kidney whatever you can live with
one right yeah you can take your kids
bro they would take your kidney stitch
you back up which is a tub filling up
with ice leave you on ice and you woke
up with a [ __ ] don't go and listen
don't go nowhere oh my god looking up
your story that's your story at least
nothing there was a scam going on for a
couple of years
oh no they caught him or they couldn't
find them because the people were taking
your kidney and going right to the
airport they had the flight plan then
like your kidney was authorized by five
they want us flight to Switzerland by 7
a.m. bye-bye
and your kidneys on a bag with ice
around it oh my god [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
they do it's like human trafficking yeah
it's the same thing man somebody's
really rich and they need something you
want years ago when I first moved here I
auditioned for a show on for Showtime
and I went all the way the producers and
I want to begin some names and it was
this show they canceled that for the
first season because it was also based
on true stories and one of the episodes
was a dude that was filthy rich that
lived like in Texas and how was his go
find her I was like his pseudo bodyguard
but no a shot they got a claim it was I
got like really great reviews I was like
episode 8 I was really excited about it
I was like critical it was a girl like
people really liked it it was different
this episode was about a guy who was
filthy rich had more money but couldn't
guns dick car cause he needed a kidney
all he wanted was kidneys so this guy's
job was to bring him different people
and say what about
and he would go he looks kind of morose
I'm looking for a guy looks a little bit
more up but he I want some uppity
kidneys you know saying like the guy was
very eccentric and there was the same
scam this guy had 30 days to live and he
had so he had millions of dollars and
only wanted was a kidney match but
everybody who they brought him was wrong
I forget how the episode ended because
it was [ __ ] 30 [ __ ] years I got
what I was gonna get on the pot since
then but yeah it was about those type of
people that that's what they did well
did you find anything like that for uh
there's some stuff at hospitals but
they're saying at least Snopes as the
the bathtub one isn't real something
will I'm telling you something you own a
bathtub you'd wake up with a note your
kidneys gun medical [ __ ] is crazy any
man I just had my knee operated and how
do you feel about me when you get an
operation it's crazy any man it's just
like you know the anesthesia everything
you gotta remember it's a different
world today Nick it really isn't I know
this [ __ ] guy left me in pain as any
left for Cabo and he's making out with a
chick I said and I like the doctor I
told him you left me in agony and
meanwhile you're on the beach making out
I couldn't get ahold of you for a week I
was screaming he was giggling his ass so
if he loves me as a good guy he's good
good surgeon but you know they just
operate they don't tell you what you're
what you're in for
you know why you had a bad team man
how'd it go in there and clean it up you
know yeah Nate and even now a month
later mom sorry [ __ ] bro they don't talk
to you and I learned that after my first
knee surgery but they do refer you for
physical therapy that's what I'm doing
that you gotta go to the physical
therapy they're all the [ __ ] odd yeah
and it's tough to get appointments
because you gotta contend with other
people by the time you [ __ ] got me in
you know he got me guy likes me yes they
basically get you in there yeah and by
the time you get in there you can't miss
the appointment that they like you and
you listen to them and you do the
homework yeah
they got you the homework they give you
a second visit no and then they put you
in the rotation what's this you're not
like a big shot you gotta show up there
5:15 the morning
to be on a bicycle spinning of the
[ __ ] ball 4:13 hey got me walking
down the hallway yeah they got you doing
a bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of [ __ ] so my
brother I was up for this job with my
brother he's like well fictiony fix you
me because you got a Skype I'm like what
the [ __ ] this skype got to do with my
knee this guy's out of his mind he's
gotta fix uni because then you have a
Skype like I can fix my knee so I could
Skype I don't want to say that home but
that's my brother he's just he's so
crazy in a way he thinks dad you know
you gotta fix your name cuz then you got
a Skype like a [ __ ] Skype I could
Skype without fixing my knee United mean
my knee wasn't that bad but it was
bothering me in bed I'm [ __ ] now my
son's bought a minute did you Skype yet
did you Skype a home not yet Skype your
ass that's a - I might have to ride a
horse I might do this project in Italy
so I might be kind of cool I never
worked over there overseas look at so I
heal all that [ __ ] I refuse to go to the
dentist I hate the dentist I refuse to
go to doctors you ever have a dry socket
what's firm your eyeball
no it's after the delay I had a guy pull
my tooth then it was one of the worst
[ __ ] pains and the guy couldn't see
it it was almost like death and they
couldn't see that I had a dry socket but
it's a it's it's an infection you can
get after an extraction you don't ever
want to get one it's really bad it feels
like death and then you know because all
you had a dry socket I never felt such a
headache even I was in New York I was
screaming with pain cuz the guy [ __ ]
around my tooth he couldn't get my tooth
out he's [ __ ] around when I trying to
pull it trying to pull it in and then I
saw my develop that dry socket member
years ago you'd get gas they put a mask
on your face gas mask I hated that I was
always close to phobic I hated putting a
big mask on man make you pass out yeah
yeah make you real it seemed you'd seed
heads like 2,000 feet high I didn't go
[ __ ] hallucinate I'm gonna be as
honest as I can with you the last the
dentistry has Update game also and you
know me dog I will come
I go to those places to complain so I
don't have to go back and I ought to be
honest with you I'll give you a hundred
bucks if you told me that share it's a
more my dentists don't hurt no more not
as much I go over here into the corner
this Armenian dude dog
they [ __ ] take that Armenian cocaine
they put inside your gum I just went ten
days ago
the day after Christmas I was doing 26
for a [ __ ] cat right over here you go
in there she's the nicest lady in the
world right they cook you up 8:00 in the
morning I went that takes balls per
gallon because that's my fainting zone
I still haven't woken up yet hey I live
too faint you know that oh really
I can't see needles on like people with
needles coming around pass out I'll take
needles but is gonna be on my terms I
got to show up early I want to get it
out of the way because the more I think
about it I'm gonna go down Wow so ten
o'clock I'm not gonna give you a blow
mouth Kramden yes yes don't give me
blood at the ten o'clock one of the
afternoons like it'll work you want my
blood I gotta see you at 8:30 quick dick
Magoo I want to get it out of the way
guess I'm gonna go down and then I don't
want to [ __ ] up my day so I bring the
iPod with me the iPad whatever the [ __ ]
it is the music yeah I put the speakers
on and there's one song I listen to
every time I nod oh yay komova by
Santana I put my arm out and I keep it
right here right and while I wait I keep
taking it to the start that I must
listen to it 20 times before the needle
comes in my arm
I just keep clicking a thing like a
[ __ ] as soon as it goes that that sour
think it did a lamb as soon as that goes
I click it buy back and the black lady
the black lady puts the [ __ ] tube
around my own dad dad dad dad I keep
clicking it click on it click on it
until she [ __ ] puts my arm down and I
don't feel nothing I gotta be honest
trading the last three is one lady mr.
vain and that [ __ ] killed me when I
got the surgery for my nose that morning
was depth but you had a sinus yeah they
cleaned out the old coke rocks like I'm
chiseled out of it yeah yeah
better now you see the for president you
look at my nose do you see the four
presidents you get Nicole and ask it be
it what's that oh well they put the cash
didn't ya tremendous how'd you come out
all right I'm here sitting when you do
it cuz I'm fake about 18 months ago I
did it when I turned 50 we drove me yeah
we drove what you do you do the Twilight
and did you do the tube in your [ __ ]
no I know what you take Twilight for the
no anesthesia I put you to sleep listen
I don't know I don't ask questions you
do the proper thought hey let's look at
the dark I go we all right here I think
it's well not all right I already told
somebody with your name and your phone
numbers so if I come out of here all
night before you had a cleanse yes
tremendous how was that
that's that rough won't listen for the
[ __ ] Gentiles it was the roughest
night of my life
all right listen what do you drink he
drinks him cementum you some [ __ ] you
mix it with water and you sit on six
feet from the toilet you put the remote
there when you tell your wife you give
it a 58 other going go-go hotel and find
yourself a hotel times do you go you go
about first you go lightly right well we
got to talk about this yellow first you
okay so let's say it's bleed rolled me
at five in the morning no because I just
had so mine was at 6 a.m. right so it's
12 hours before the surgery yeah drink
the drink it so it's 6 o'clock but
people don't know for you young
[ __ ] when you turn 50 you get
two [ __ ] letters in the mail you get
one from your assurance telling you that
you have to come in for a colonoscopy
and you play stupid
you take that 11 you rip it up because
you hit a scorpion and you know : and
you know there's a finger coming in the
ass cuz I've been getting the finger in
the ass twice a year for years now yeah
I'm like you I got the Sagan's shirt I
use that thing
yeah all right scan irritable bowel
syndrome trouble
I don't know there's no bowels so years
ago a guy turned me upside down that's
another word for a listen I got a
problem taking shits all day then stop
taking [ __ ] we'll call it a [ __ ] y'all
think when we were kids you do you think
every Bri oski with the water you reckon
it was like cement without the color is
good mine had two hours later boom if
that didn't work
prune juice a la carte prune juice ain't
no lattice of prune juice
within one hour you hold onto your
stomach crying remember the [ __ ]
Jerry Tom Jarrett all the peace I love
my love wasn't you pink it was my dog I
could drink that [ __ ] all day well I
wanted to drink that Geritol I could
drink that [ __ ] there was something else
I liked as a kid that I was addicted I
mean the first time I drank my chocolate
no guys the Bosco I'm a move I'm a
bicycle like a [ __ ] for a long
time you got to make a decision between
Bosco quick by school quickly I was a
quick dude wasn't one a strawberry how's
my Jasco gang what's the one with
strawberry at a jump real quick for a
while then that went back to [ __ ]
Bosco then I stopped drinking chocolate
milk who gives a [ __ ] you like those egg
creams did you like a vanilla ice much
[ __ ] yes I gotta make that nose I used
to make those I get because I'll just
what I'll usually can eat green what
I'll do is and I don't like them with
[ __ ] what do they make them with I
ain't put now step put oshi syrup and a
little bit of no you got to get the o
bets you bets it's you beat yes that's
the best I'm a Hershey's guy you're this
all right that's I put two inches of
chocolate because I like it sweet right
I put two inches of real milk or if I
don't feel it [ __ ] on the light side
like I gotta take a heavy cream if
you're gonna go deep you might as well
go and like narcos to him saying yeah
I'll stare that [ __ ] up real
fast you guys start with the salt
setback as I'm putting the self serving
you do know I know I listen my first
experience in that whole world my mom
had a drunk my mom was partners to the
dry cleaner because it was a bookie
operation upstairs
yeah it was on Tremont Avenue
Brown the Bronx and 30 yards from the
drycleaners it was called quality
cleaners and thirty yards from that
there was those quantum places they used
to put rat Italian I stood this done
three colored one yeah and puts right on
it and stir it up yeah when I was a kid
I drink I drink too when I was a [ __ ]
there was you know they make you run for
hours Doug oh yeah nothing like a good
lemon ice or good fresh ice I mean back
then I mean you know I loved all that
[ __ ] house egg creams I could drink the
problem here is you go to Jerry's deli
well four dollars for an egg cream hang
on they make it like [ __ ] you look at
them go I you [ __ ] serious
you people are thieves 454 450
I can make egg creams for four [ __ ]
days for me only four days Rob you're
blind we can make a Christmas Rob you
blind for 14 days that's crazy
really if 450 is one o'clock more 50s
are you are you down the flocked in milk
and to Kiko yourself club soda little
milk and get the [ __ ] no bet he
doesn't like GU Ben where the [ __ ] you
look fine little better you can find it
we're in a some sort and some markets
we're about here yes well you found that
he I tell you well yeah I know where to
find it you can find that the uncle
Bernie's is a deli right by my house
they sell it oh but yeah you you be
eating I'm gonna check on that [ __ ] no I
got you I stood in the first about the
best hot dog in New York I had one a
couple of months ago I was in Brooklyn I
had a [ __ ] soubrette on this thing
cut us a break guys is today amazing so
Brett in the water with this mustard and
sauerkraut so simple
it's the best [ __ ] hotdog going down
and see sorry mother Seaside Park what
is Joker sauerkraut is my savage would
ya yeah are you Jewish
no I never had in Seaside Park there was
a guy that was this as Jesus left
Chicago and give you a that breath for
20 bucks oh my god he make the spice he
get the sad bread chilly but dope it up
he read open up spicy chili I'm singer
so it was chilly molested wood onions
with
[ __ ] good I could eat eight of those
and then they give us something yeah no
dosa Brett's go down nice I think you
would love him Lee has they're just
standing up I'm standing up outside
talking [ __ ] to the boys give him
another round like the way people drink
cocktails Oh like that I could sit with
you and Leigh with Leigh and Nick right
now in 70-degree weather stone to the
gill
talking to each other you want a dog yet
just like that and we're headed to a
place to eat a [ __ ] that's the best
when you're actually headed to a place
to eat a man you bump into a sad bright
guy and the noise or the dogs are on
fire because you know there's gonna be
traffic baby Papa but you know there's
gonna be drama and all singing you go
you know what guys let's get a dog just
in case this trap because I'm [ __ ]
stop just hold me oh honey I'll make it
the long night the guys liking you that
you got dogs yeah Lily I just came out
you with me I just came out the buns are
nice and huh and he gives you that first
one he takes that stick and he puts that
mustard and he puts those [ __ ] you
don't give me let me get a can of go
with like an agent Stanley gives no I'm
not a big Nathan's enormous a bright guy
I had to make a choice and I went with
Sabra you grab that [ __ ] cam with the
napkin if they got class you give me
that good falafel and they give you a
napkin for the can that's old school
class that's right and you open up the
[ __ ] can and you bite into the hot
dog and that onion mixes with that
[ __ ] mushroom and you could put in a
[ __ ] a cream soda oh my god I'm a
coca-cola type of do I like coke I've
always liked my mommy la I'm a coca-cola
and what's a while cream so I would
never switch governments and if I had a
girl or his drink was my second choice
like RC Cola Oh like a [ __ ] by
storm a coca-cola and no ketchup no
catch then you don't even have ketchup
if he's a real hot dog man he won't have
ketchup now a grilled New York hotdog
dude no no old-school
that's a presidential try it is it is
you just draw a hot dog there's people
out here again oh my god
Melissa did that program to give it to
the kids in the school you can't compete
I told my wife don't bring the wrong
ketchup out cuz I'll stab you than that
I'm with hot dog ketchup for the
hamburger she has for the [ __ ]
ketchup I almost died but she's five she
don't understand maybe a lot of times
she said I could talk her into being a
civilian [ __ ] some bright man some
dog know that submit my buddy has one
can't get him out here that he's my
buddy to get listen I get the car for 25
grand the license dr. Hart and the thing
is out of juvie the problem is you gotta
buy everything from sad Brett out of
Jersey they send it to you that's why
they send you the hot dogs the buns the
chili go on lonely but you got to get
everything from there yeah look what
they have online they mail it right the
house I wonder if it's worth it [ __ ]
yeah it's worth it you mean to sell it
they'll have a stand to do whatever the
[ __ ] you want what it's what I would
like to do lookups a bread calm look at
I'll tell you everything you [ __ ]
need and print it up on the screen here
you know you know what is another thing
that I [ __ ] love I know I thought I
know three people for sure look I don't
mean to interrupt you no gang for the
bottom of my heart so I better come is
available for okay just look up look up
sad bread hot dogs it's gonna be
something like that sigh bread hot dogs
not come Wow
years ago there was a girl in front of
[ __ ] in front of sag right down
Wilshire right there she pull up with a
wagon and a hot dog truck with the sad
red flag I almost died well here this
has to be 15 years ago when I first made
like running all the time I'm a it if
you went to sag she'd be out there and I
spun I actually became friends let's go
hang out before I became high I would go
down there for I had dogs we my buddy
Mike cassileth
would smoke a joint going you wanna go
get some sad brats and we go down and
one day we caught her she was just about
to rap and she said I'll give me this
last six I got just give me whatever you
want
and we started talking he said if you
don't want man well husband some Jersey
I go back there I went I fell in love
with these things she goes we moved out
here I never saw Seibert hot dog again
we invested
all right they had the card they had
everything everything but she goes you
know what for us to live was 350 hotdogs
yawns eh
yeah yeah I know I gonna survive she
kind of knew what she was doing but she
now I'm lying to you she knew what she
was doing she was doing a good job the
chili was good it was the sad red stuff
out of a can
it was the same stuff you got in New
York same stuff
she wasn't toast to the bread okay
she wasn't toasting the bread bread is
important the bread is important it's
gotta be the sad bread bun sad bond is
special that's the buzzer small look at
it so you could order all that here it
is you can order the [ __ ] right now
for [ __ ] for y'all listen the old
[ __ ] how much is the cart I don't think
that's a card that cuts for call for
pricing and extension 13 for more
information Oh Oh [ __ ] whatever the
[ __ ] tabletop anyone new on table time
the real deal though you want yeah I
don't want no [ __ ] sorry you want to
sell no I want to sell it you don't go
to tell you when you go to Yankee spring
training
yeah you ever go there I do once in a
while they're all you see them down
there every carts got [ __ ] in sad red
hot dogs in Florida and Tampa Florida
when I went to do timely 10 [ __ ]
years ago that's what I hate the two
days I was there Sabbath right outside
the hotel some guy was there how you
doing man was it or you got several had
those were you from this I'm from Queens
yeah only been down in 15 years I came
for spring training and never left one
of those [ __ ] good yeah it was my
father owned one of these and it was in
the garage I drove it down here and I do
this now he was selling that sad Brett
dogs he was FINA I'm just trying to make
a [ __ ] living yeah but me those are
in my blood no I that was the first hot
dog I know why I'm surprised no one's
brought it out here no one's that
because it's too tough you don't walk in
LA listen that's that's part of it I
mean for years when you meet people who
like to eat food
they live out here now there's a big
argument about they don't make pizza
cause of the water they don't do this
cuz of the water don't do this cuz of
the pricing and that's half true let me
tell you what the other side of that
argument is dictatorial your father had
a pizza place with your uncle and 1940
they worked there for 20 years and they
bought the joint for the dew before he
died and they added something to the
pizza crust and they worked hard in
Brooklyn I mean you became a child and
John you worked for him and you knew the
recipe not you and John decided your
wife didn't like New York Nick so you
want to move to LA I know look at the
passion you have for living and you will
have that same [ __ ] passion for your
food
you and your wife opened up a [ __ ]
Italian place Redondo Beach let's just
put a scenario here 19 1989 when you
could still own [ __ ] and buy property
and you could run like a white man okay
hey you are [ __ ] using the money got
from this place oh you use excuse me
you're using Parmesan cheese from New
York you're getting mom what's a Ralph
Lauren you know the water let's not get
that extreme right but you get know all
the food you get in pepperoni that is
[ __ ] top knots the same pepperoni
they sell at Ray's beach so you know you
you one of those guys you work from
sunrise to sundown
here you are selling your pie the best
the best in anywhere in California
people are driving from all over your
pizza but guess what bro every day 10
times a night you got to sit there with
your father's [ __ ] recipe and look at
10 kids walk by your place with a
Domino's box now if you're now like me
it crushes my insides when I say that
that you'll save 10 bucks to avoid what
pizza is right dude [ __ ] dominoes
junk yeah so as a whole as somebody who
really cares about their
food as a businessman you consider it a
competitor and you work around it but
somebody who prides what they're doing
whether it's Italian food Chinese food
Jew food Cuban food and on a sudden
[ __ ] you know in Miami there's a
Cuban competitor in everybody it's not
pool trophy cow it's poor yo we spoke
about it and they got black beans and
rice
Papa Carla's know what's the one out
here I'll pour your look for it spoiled
trophy cow oil trumpet cow is like
McDonald's but they got a nice chicken
filet and black beans and white rice
then you get a side onions and fried
bananas and it's not [ __ ] bad guys
I'm CUBAN I'm telling you it's not bad
that I understand it's good food it's
good takeaway food but if I brought a
recipe on here that my father worked on
for 60 years and I saw a kid walk down
my street with a Domino's box I'd shoot
that [ __ ]
it breaks your heart that's a sin to
break your heart so that's why I see I
don't see the commitment how many Cuban
restaurants they around there listen
they're for [ __ ] human dude moved out
from Miami you take a refugee that
cooked in Miami and cooked at a good
hotel in Miami and he cooked that home
stout you were fooling you brought him
out here you'd make millions like you'd
make millions just from his Jennifer
Lopez walked in there you'd have you
wouldn't have a [ __ ] table available
at night and then you'd sell the dump
after he and light it on fire and open
up another place that's what a but you
get my drift if it's it won't happen out
here because the creation you made show
me one Chinese restaurant that has pork
around here the fried pork that you come
in and get sliced that's a New York
style I'll tell you three of them that
have it but they got the [ __ ] fat in
the middle and the one part of me this
kind of brown and it's not cold shy
person no but this is like one time soup
you can't get this in open so some
people get pissed I just don't eat it I
don't complain because I know that I'm
19 nothing kosher I'm
move on with my [ __ ] life I Know
Nothings like back home and we were get
takeout would say look what we're gonna
have tonight chinks all right let's have
chinks you know and then we'd get that
[ __ ] in a cardboard box and it was
delicious right
you know we got some Italian food to
like that is acceptable yeah
does the one is very good the one with
the homemade noodles delicious adored
yeah the Arabiya nominee the bowler
there's good it's good it's very good
good
don't think as it got a little bunched
up together the pasta hell that's how
it's suppose you know that's homemade
you'll eat that [ __ ] you get eBay
when it's hot right with it's hot yeah
otherwise it was the temperature was
[ __ ] Nick sauce was a level on top of
Bolton I thought don't taste the street
in there [ __ ] food yeah I could taste
the [ __ ] Street in their food and I
just made that so that's just you know
once it settles it's gonna get better
and better you know got the pork in
there and at the sausage I didn't put
the meatballs that [ __ ] is good right
you just could dip in it
that's real sauce you don't know let's
pretend you'd open up a joint with four
little tables yeah you get a bunch of
people in there and you kept it just
like this Nick sauce that's it
to me boss bye no don't stop doing
Alfredo no don't don't get fancy don't
get fancy
yeah you know what you're getting this
beer right what's your I'll fix it was
simple hip it's simple you make it
killing but then again people come to
you and say oh we went to this Italian
restaurant that you've actually been to
no it's [ __ ] junk and no it's
tremendous you as a real [ __ ] chef
will go what the [ __ ] is going on with
society I wanted to an elevator in Long
Island and when I walked in there with
two kids with Domino's boxes oh and the
father was standing there I want to let
the kids out of the elevator and grab
the damn enjoy you [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you [ __ ] crazy you're in long out
of this a pizza joint every every every
neighbor and you're getting [ __ ]
dominoes you claims no all islands got
pizza up D oh it was never so [ __ ]
embarrassed what the even oh my god hey
what happened so me and Lee have a
mutual friend
John but he's one of the owners at V Mac
and he's a brown belt v mecca's in
jujitsu place first place I ever did
jujitsu he's still different
even on tongue over there he's from
above New York he's from like on how
outside of New York City where it snowed
39 feet my nose last week huh so he went
back to bring his new bride to be up
there that introduced it to the parents
you know there's a girl he fell in love
with Peruvian you're a real cool
sweetheart and he wanted to bring her
home and then we had all these [ __ ]
plans well they went back there and gods
in opted with the weather so badly that
she got [ __ ] sick and slept Christmas
Day and she couldn't get out of bed the
whole [ __ ] thing so he wanted to call
me and wish me a Merry Christmas and we
chit-chatted and I go what are your
plans he goes with him we're thinking
and going down into the city and seeing
the ball drop and I go no you're not
why not like because you're not doing
that I go you're not wasting your time I
go I grew up down I never saw the ball
drop it's embarrassing all right Stanley
mind your [ __ ] business like when you
talking about hangover he'll give me the
time and then we're gonna have done a
Mulberry Street and got Italian food I
go pack that's wrong right there also he
goes what are you talking about he goes
what are you talking about more buries a
[ __ ] tourist trap everybody knows
that now it's done Dino you won't really
Talia food you gotta go up to art that
having to up there in the [ __ ] Bronx
by what Tremont intersects bro they got
food there that'll [ __ ] knock your
socks off Dominic's and Mario's just
those two that's where you [ __ ] stole
attention let me tell you something Lee
they called me from the [ __ ]
restaurant Jack and they were like the
only ones to talk to here and they were
like thank you for a further mind you I
was just up there about four years ago
we started talking
who probably good I go to savor that
John but you're never gonna eat like
that ever again in your life he goes
Joey when you break the bread the smoke
came out of it he goes toot it was just
[ __ ] sensational what's called Mario's
all right the revenues he took pictures
with the dude he was like why wouldn't I
go to Mulberry Street I go because
that's where every sucker goes to that
sucker Street now everybody wants to see
The Sopranos yeah you gotta they e3z
it's Chinese people cooking Italian
that's a nice guy that's all it is
that's all gun that's how you take a
girlfriend when you're a dummy you don't
even go down there no more right you
think that it ain't like years ago
joints it's gone now
and even if the three of them though
there is one bakery there I still know
that's that's not bad no I don't man no
but the whole thing now is a show it's
just two guys the front standing it's
not good to walk make him believe yeah
you don't wanna finish big mistake
I just sort of have a feast where my
mother knows little San Gennaro when I
was st. Gennaro now [ __ ] it's all
commercial I used to go down there like
I've ever go down there with some
Italian kids when I was like in the
seventh grade the yeah I got left back I
went over there what it was the same kid
that got his head caught and uh we went
to a peep show and he ran out of corn a
seashell and the [ __ ] thing shut it
what a mess right oh really what the
[ __ ] was his name I Cameron was name
would know about fast the glass used to
go up the glass would go up real quick
oh wait I you'd be right in the middle
of jerking off and the front glass would
[ __ ] this was way before sexual
harassment ha s is funny he'd been and
he never meant that peeps you into a
peep show we not like that a forties
show world on 46 oh I was a young kid
though I won't with my dad and I
remembered we have a story about me
asking about them but about what about
like what they were and will you tell
you they just were you go see naked
woman I didn't understand it I was like
five even want to go in there that
you wanna see a little woman's monkey oh
thank you shocked when I was a young kid
and I saw a woman's [ __ ] I almost
[ __ ] died I [ __ ] ran the first
time right yeah I didn't know what was
going on I didn't know how to calibrate
it I didn't know what was going I was so
embarrassed and even asked my mom but I
just kept it to myself he is yeah it's
just like the first time you're banged
like you didn't know what you like I
don't even remember if I got it in I
didn't even know if I did it I didn't do
it I was like I think I did it I wasn't
sure you know what I was doing I was an
amateur no I'm telling I was a [ __ ]
hammer the girl was a deadbeat so what
are you gonna do she was laying there
like half dead that was what it was if I
think back now I'm on my time I just
like dry humping if we could've just
drive home forever I've been fine yeah
it's safe and happy safer than [ __ ]
coming your pants you come a little in
your pants you want a little funny and
it's no fun until dinner and then you
take a shower nobody gets hurt you know
if you're lucky she lets you suck above
the tip see you let's just see like a
little bit of the color you something -
you [ __ ] dry humping is good because
you get a laugh you know you know that
there's a paid day yeah and they always
tell you keep doing this and Christmas
2008 I'll give you a taste it's Newton
it's 1994 I always loved it I had a
girlfriend that had me alone for six
months telling me she was only give me a
piece of [ __ ] on the last day of school
me Annie and then the last day of school
she goes she couldn't do it that she
didn't love me that she didn't know she
really wasn't my girlfriend I was [ __ ]
Christ
I was being able to Christ Oh sixth
grade beyond crushed sixth grade right
and I mean it was guys at home you all
know when you fall in love the first
time that you lose interest I was a
Bruce Lee kid like I believed everything
he taught everything he said bad ass and
then he died
that's all once I got
Catholic school that's all I did that
was my outlet at the Catholic school I
went to McKinley after McKinley I went
up to my mother's bar I ate something
with her I think my karate uniform when
I go to karate from 4:30 to [ __ ] 9
that was my life guys that was all I
thought about I go back had the incense
in my room and I slept by myself at
night my mom wouldn't get home till 3:30
so you went the martial arts way back I
was a kid yeah
now Bruce ladies that those double
triple features and all of a sudden I
went to the seventh grade Nick and I
just something happened to my deck in my
mind I saw girls it started the sixth
grade for me Wow
I went I went to Miami and I met two
girls Natasha and Rebecca two Cuban
girls and we played like Greece yeah you
don't say anyway we play like Greece
like we didn't kiss we just [ __ ] held
each other
yeah if Aggies [ __ ] and we were
talking the phone till my mother got the
first phone book and that was the end of
that romance it was like a tour law a
phone book yeah he's on the phone
forever forever talking where nonsense
father and that was the end of my
romance that was I was a free man it
didn't matter Pete Rose was going
through the world you know saying yeah
it didn't matter of my world I had the
Mets I had Pete Rose at karate and then
that 75 seventh grade hmm I [ __ ] saw
this [ __ ] guy like I asked this girl
out first and Timmy Holloway's listening
the girl's name is Davis Rodriguez Cuban
girl just beautiful she's talking about
a girl named Jeanette Blasco that was
back and she was Puerto Rican I had a
sister I was even hotter than she was
called a vet don't I still remember
these fries that Wow they were Puerto
Rican straw man not my Porto Rican
babies Rodriguez was good-looking and
they'll forget in the schoolyard
McKinley going up there going I like
that
a sure other day that she's like I'm
very flattered but I choose not to go
out with you I was like [ __ ] I can't get
my game while his [ __ ] was
and then I saw this guy started hanging
out with this kid I do this kid from
packing that will never really crazy
about him he was kind of Cuban so I had
to give him the benefit of that but then
I saw his sister oh my goodness Boston
she was my age
skinny dirty looking oh just how I like
him long greasy looking hair and [ __ ]
lanky just a thoroughbred of a walk to
get in the era oh yeah
first time having one of the movies with
her and the grandmother the brother
couldn't no and the father couldn't no
the father and the mother would divorce
but he lived in the base to make a move
oh I gotta get romantic you know you
just can't go right for the mug yours -
no it's - you don't even work at Price
I'm waiting gasps I had to take her in
the grandmother to the movies the first
time and then for about 90 days if I
went over there I'd have to watch teeth
this is [ __ ] crazy because I was just
thinking about this I would have to
watch TV with her and the grandmother
not to change the story that's how
[ __ ] back of mind I am and that you
were talking about your mind you are how
old uh 55 do you write things down I'm
starting I write my whole day down yeah
like my whole day has to be written down
Nick if not it's not gonna work like if
my day is not written down it's not
gonna work I don't like I don't have to
know where I gotta be at 8:00 a.m. I
gotta do this 212 I gotta call this guy
I gotta call that guy up here I gotta
write things I'm doing for the week like
I have a notebook like this if not Nick
it gets [ __ ] thrown away but this guy
just died no no this is notes for this
guy just died right what's his kid's
name when we were kids and he [ __ ] he
gotten aware of everybody I wanted to
[ __ ] there was two people who I still
hate after 55
okay there's two [ __ ] that
[ __ ] me up when I was a kid there was
three but I forgave the third the first
[ __ ] that [ __ ] me up when I
was a kid was that [ __ ] Donny Osmond
with his [ __ ] he sang that one bad
apple and then he [ __ ] got the TV
show the girl I was in love with this
girl I'm talking to you about she had to
stay home every [ __ ] Friday night
don't watch [ __ ] Donny and Marie cuz
she was in love with Donny I was gonna
shoot Donny in the head like a Kennedy
do you understand he was getting in
between me and my [ __ ] romance the
other guy who got in between my [ __ ] was
that dude who just died that dirty son
of a [ __ ] The Partridge Family that
[ __ ] he [ __ ] up a lot of
relationships to me when I was 12 I used
to want to bang be [ __ ] up more [ __ ]
for me in the Love Boat The Love Boat
used to always [ __ ] my game up cuz at
nine o'clock
you get all mugged up to them and swap
spit then The Love Boat will come on and
they freeze up on you and then you have
to play dead possum for an hour and by
11:00 the mother would show up from
playing cards and you went home with a
[ __ ] cold nut because of The Love
Boat because of some [ __ ] on a boat
and [ __ ] all night bro when you're no 12
and you got that nuts going and you go
home with cold nut we don't evacuate we
don't ejaculate whatever when you're
like under 13 and you get hauling down
blue balls and they call it blue boy
that actually happens at one time I'm
one nuts weren't so bad oh my god my one
that's roll up when I was about 13 cuz I
had a nut I was really a nuttin somebody
was ready to do something look at the
cops game something happen and I run
home and you come back flies when you're
a kid and you can all fly it up like
that that thing's ready to shoot out of
there like a missile sure I don't know
what we were doing I was making out with
a girl we're about to dry-hump and the
father came home tried to run out the
back door bro the next day I woke up and
I had a pain in my deck and the
following day I woke up and my nut was
falling I don't forget my mother fell
asleep
watch the TV on the edge of the bed
right the TV was on like 6:00 in the
morning and she's passed out
and I wrote oh my god Mima and I wake
her up and she goes okay what happened I
go look at my nuts I must have been
[ __ ] 12 the feel I should just pick
them up like a mom would do she goes
you're all right
get that myself and go buy your uncle I
don't know nothing happened that means
did she get nothing you get another son
Mitel stay hell and that way I'm never
forget that waking her up like 6:00 in
the morning go muck I gotta show you
something because it was dark with you
nuts in her face it was about three
inches away
[ __ ] crazy man some [ __ ] boy that's
some crazy [ __ ] yeah well you're a young
kid and you don't nut I remember my
first Hickey is Chekhov vo Elka like
half-black half-puerto Rican
yeah only Puerto Rican chicks gave you
yeah I didn't know what it was when you
were kids dilly chinks I would dare give
you a key will Puerto Rican chicks Oh
easy if they didn't have a brother I had
a brother you couldn't give him a
[ __ ] band-aid on all my friends said
put some makeup on cuz I thought my my
mother and if you hung out with the
brother and you were [ __ ] the sister
you better not have a hickey from the
sister either
yeah well my mother ripped the [ __ ]
band-aid right off like an idiot it was
something I mean the girl was amazing
like I didn't know what she was doing
she blew me away she was out of my
league she was so [ __ ] powerful and
sexy I was like wow I was like I never
saw her again
because she was so good I just remember
her name viola my mother hit me in the
[ __ ] head and my father looked in
goes oh that was it he had nothing you
know my mom got mad at that [ __ ] man I'm
caught
yeah well my mom put a bandaid on it go
for a hickey yeah it was the first time
we got caught shooting us time inking
somebody no no no I never even bothered
of course now I never really caught me
in in that you know in the act
close quote you know but never like in
the act you know with
that girl I used to dry-hump from my
bedroom used to drive my mother crazy if
she was over my mom will make me leave
the bedroom door open you can't
disrespect me am i right
that's what I got in trouble with my
parents was my mom was [ __ ] first
girlfriend and shut the dust that my
parents don't like that don't you
understand she was a little [ __ ]
butyne and you know she liked to shut
the door I said tell me timing oh oh
yeah you know she was [ __ ] more
advanced than me she was only 15 how
dare she
well you know she had nice titties I was
a titty guy it was a different [ __ ]
world it really was you know was so
exciting had a little stereo with the
8-track player I thought I was the [ __ ]
Victoria Principal on my door I'm a
Victoria Principal Dallas it's a girl
Jill Goodacre when I lived in Boulder
she was a big boulder girl she had got
to school my ex-wife and this was way
before she did and Harry Connick jr. I
think I was leaving Boulder though he
was a little before that but she was
really smart she was a Victoria's Secret
and she took all that money and bought
real estate in the boulder at that time
I see her in her farm was a name Jill
Goodacre
okay now she's married to Harry Connick
jr. she married him no but she was a
real [ __ ] Victoria's Secret model let
me see what she looked like
pull her up in her eighth day this is
[ __ ] Jill Goodacre in her [ __ ]
heyday kind of Boulder Colorado way down
a Fairview [ __ ] High School
Boulder High I'm not sure you know what
I never know I can and that I saw her
once with her dad but she was already by
that time she had security the whole
[ __ ] deal or what seemed like
security Manny Hanny her she married
Harry wait to you see Jill Goodacre once
you see her you remember she was big
when we were kids big now she's old
we'll put uh oh I know
face no no she no you don't really
that's not what she look like you go
this one over here yeah keep going keep
going see how they're gonna go with
their early Jill Goodacre just going to
Joker they got 19 [ __ ] 87 and see
what you get with Victoria's Secret
put Victoria's Secret next to that
[ __ ] joke mushy it's even you
know the title and nash's the first
thing that comes up she's a mom now
she's on phone yeah I know but this oh
wow right there with the white lacy yeah
that was her right keep going down keep
going down that's her - blue keep going
down right there oh my god - that you
made it bigger that was all we were kids
modern I mean look at that get up that's
what she looked like we were Jenn's dog
just stunning you know she was a [ __ ]
star I mean a she's beautiful look it oh
my god completely natural does not
develop that's cause I did that that's
true nobody's a medium in Colorado don't
mean that's not like just skinny and let
me tell you something let me tell you
what she grew up with Oh everything she
grew up with her till they drive you
crazy
oh the God Rose X at that time there was
three [ __ ] powerhouse families in
Boulder Jill Goodacre
the ganja's ex and Kevin call Kevin call
was real well noted because he was the
guy that played for the Baltimore Colts
and he was well known for going up
against Gaston all oh really yes I know
Kevin call was a big [ __ ] and at
that time I was getting stolen
cigarettes and his father had a [ __ ]
Roach coach and I would sell him
cigarettes you know I would make a
little more than him of the cigarettes
but at that time when I lit the bulb it
was Jill Goodacre
[ __ ] Keaveney Law no no no she's
going this bro she was the face of
victorious how old is she today she's
gotta be bleep tights without Harry how
oldest-known she don't look bad
no she's a mom she by Guerlain kids hey
kids how old was she when she Jill
Goodacre 53 yeah she's our age 64 she's
53 and she's still an attractive woman
yeah she's not my ex-wife's age where
did say she go to high school she was
born in Lubbock but I don't know about
high school insane how long a name a
little Wikipedia right there they'd been
married probably she was still [ __ ]
the real deal she she did some movies I
grew up in Boulder Colorado the daughter
a real estate broker I don't want to say
the father's name sculptures whatever
native of Lubbock and besides in Santa
Fe America with her mother good actor
married in 1994 and a Catholic ceremony
in st. Catherine she's the real deal
guys yeah that's beauty man there was no
issues there was no drama with this
broad she came out the pipe how long was
she a model for Victoria's Secret I
can't read it from here I mean she was
Victoria's Secret in 1986 80 in 1985 I
met somebody who asked me if I know Jill
Goodacre was so that's how big she was
already in 85 this is a nice so she was
two years younger than me so if I was 21
she was named [ __ ] teen yeah that
does she spotless she's flawless clean
and I sorry there's nothing no drama
this girl married she took over the
world
she bought real estate with her father
at a young age she bought all that [ __ ]
up and balls the dog so when that body
got chubby
she had property to sell off and make a
ton of money
she had that money way before the to
whatever earthquakes in California never
been moved there it all happened nothing
94 in northglenn right that's when half
of California from up there
move to Boulder they said that's it
that's when Boulder changed completely
as I was leaving Boulder they were
already coming in coming in they were
buying them properly
all right I want to give a shout out to
my girl Meg Aaron Michael Stein
Wesley de Stephan Krypton the Dakota
travel John lemon Scott Cunningham
Michael horn Bob Salomon and mr. tense
wished mr. ten steel I know you're going
through some hard times you know I love
you [ __ ] and then said you don't
me don't flip flap and go
you brought the [ __ ] sauce tonight I
got the [ __ ] around
I thought you guys are gonna eat then
you told me eight o'clock I didn't know
what was going on so hey I'm happy
[ __ ] I would take some home please
got some d2 then Leo's or brought your
dollars please take them home I got your
real deal look at this [ __ ] Lee what you
got to deal with tonight
what kind of a it's the [ __ ] best
baby oh Jesus Christ
yeah Oh what one of those is ten points
but you want one Lee I want a doll box
with a guy with a glass of milk in the
honeymooners yeah by yourself honey
mornings you get over 10 to 11:00 from
work and it's cold out and [ __ ] [ __ ] sit
down I mean she's sleeping you own the
living room you go you [ __ ] get some
coffee then you're looking on top of the
kitchen and right next to the toaster
there's some Entenmann's pound cake oh
oh what Samantha miss doughnuts enjoy
the pancakes okay if I eat this I better
have to go back to the store and get
some by the time she wakes up yeah cuz
she's gonna wake up with this crumb bun
in mind oh man crumb cake oh all that
the [ __ ] one [ __ ] the square square
the square cup of coffee
Jesus Christ you kidding me you can't
even eat there now at mines I can't oh
yeah
those who change my diet if I'm gonna
live longer no I haven't had one of
those I see him Marines he got him dog
huh they got the regular ones and the
old get one down a short apple crumb
this bakery called mullahs would would
blow you in the water
unbelievable I don't need the crumb just
that glazed estimates was thrown at heat
30 years ago they had a chocolate
doughnut that had chocolate balls on it
with powdered sugar on it that you would
eat it and you look like [ __ ] a mess
but Lee they were so look at a stuff
there was a lot of good chocolate chip
cookies when I was growing up but the
first time I had the anthem and chunks
of cookie my heart stopped because they
was soft and I'm soft they were the
first ones that was soft yeah like I'm a
Chips Ahoy dude neato I'm a Chips Ahoy
do it to the end of the time I like that
one companies chocolate chip cookies for
a while growing up but I'm a Chips Ahoy
a time to do it too so I was my thing
that was my thing
yeah however I like the crunch against
the crispy hunt what's going on victim's
body housing things going on so I'm
right I'm gonna do a miniseries next
month in Italy you got it yeah I got it
it's called the name of the rose my
first time working in Italy with my
brother John how about we shoot Italy
for I'm gonna be there two weeks in
February two weeks in March a week in
April and a week in May yeah you done
with the Spike Lee movies I'm done with
the spite way the black Landsman that
was a lot of fun
how many collaborations there how many
times you worked well like five times
maybe you've done five of his movies
yeah you think he said it in front of
everybody next film would mean this is
like what number five Nick I'm supposed
to do the what was it the bank robbery
movie but I didn't do that one but I did
jungle fever more better Malcolm X and I
did one other one too I forget and then
this one four or five I don't know but
uh was good to work with spike again I
started with him so it's kind of [ __ ]
weird
we reminisce and we were doing a lot of
the lines from the old movies we're
doing jungle fever we were doing mo
bettah
spikes you know he's a good dude he's a
good he's he man he's the first guy to
give me my start you know the first guy
that put me on the map so it's kind of
you know it's kind of fitting to go back
sometimes to who you started with you
know there are some good people
interesting people in the movie it's
this guy that's kind of a Adam driver
it's interesting guy and a few other
people he's kind of hot right now
Denzel Sun is in it there's like ballers
and that's a new year it's a new year so
I think I think it's gonna be a good
year you know the optimistic yeah I
don't know why I have a good fun but
optimistic to that the Act maybe there's
a lot of [ __ ] you know you and I talk
about a lot on the phone and I don't
pick out you for this you're a great kid
but I have my frustrations also you know
you like the people that are working
Kenny relax half of them you know they
can't even you don't half the people I
know so I think going to me to come
right crazy alright even [ __ ] funny
so okay you don't want to give me the
work that's fine
he's funnier than these [ __ ] people
how'd you do the other night pretty good
I did my everything new huh
I want to give a shout out to the fourth
wall phone we're [ __ ] comedy is king
you want to be a comedian go to the
fourth wall alright and give it a shot
you just go up there in front of a bunch
of comedians there's no alcohol there's
no [ __ ] glitz it's not Madison Square
Garden it's fighting for your [ __ ]
life you do comedy in front of comics
bro you pay five dollars you get five
minutes like a savage old style did you
used to go to long like it was going
well and then I just like the last
minute I say I was glad you didn't I
should just stop like the minute earlier
I got the light I started getting a
little bit too cocky I guess you did
good for four minutes
I have for like five I do the same jokes
as last time not just rich enough all
new stuff good for you we congratulate
it was
I was gonna do some most as some of the
old stuff but with this guy Eric who is
hosting and I did but we're talking
earlier so we just I just did start
talking about that and can I tell you
people sounds fun again no means that
interrupt you Lee I love you like a
brother the night that broke one night I
was taping a special and people louvers
in the house and they started clapping
for him to come on stage listen to me
I'm going to tell you some 9/11 people
wouldn't come on stage
this poor kid will update took the stage
and I knew that this would have been
easy and I never intended to get him up
at this stage I knew that he had a fear
of going up in the stage but I learned
that by tricking somebody into stage
it's a lot easier than when something
fuzzy oh you know what Nick like if a
kid ever comes up to your gums
uncle Nick can I talk to you listen man
I want to be a stand-up comic I just
don't know what to do I'm scared to go
up the first time trick up just go okay
fine
send the bomb and call the club and put
him up sign him up and then take him up
there watch your friend who's a comedian
and let them call his name he's got no
choice all that [ __ ] he's got help to
run up there and do it and he'll think
of the material to say and he'll get it
over with and you helped him up you
created a monster now that he'll
continue doing it because it was that
easy but when people think about doing
something they [ __ ] falter and they
won't get on stage the first time he got
forced to go on stage he had no choice
he knew that either he won on stage or
they would harass him later on right
yeah pretty much
he knew he was a tight I didn't even
consider that doing and that really
works bro the best way the teacher can
have a swim is to throw him off a boat
right yeah there's no other way but to
get in there and that's how it was proof
we've never dreamed of going up on stage
we had this discussion a
million [ __ ] times he never dreamed
going up on stage well I'd love to stand
up but I never thought I'd be on stage
right before I did the special he was
started [ __ ] around up and receded be
on stage
yeah receiver yeah yeah you started
[ __ ] around and receding I go looking
[ __ ] League going on space because
sometimes you got to push people like
come on that's your dream he never
discussed it so he went up on stage and
it's so amazing that now he goes down
there by himself I had a spot of flap as
I left him there you know most guys will
tip he [ __ ] stayed he stayed and
finished out the night like a gentleman
[ __ ] did you need listen man the best
thing I all that [ __ ] is watching those
comics well yeah it was interesting
watching some people just kind of go
forward and like kind of like I'm doing
like I have I have a couple I have a
list on my phone of things that I but
spark the idea but I don't have like a
written out joke but there are a couple
people while going down the list who
were cool again with even sound state
like in two weeks when I figure out this
middle part it'll be good so they kind
of exciting to think about getting to
that part like ok well nobody nobody
really bombed no yeah a snake like
nobody really albeit it was weak as I
thought about this when I was driving
nobody bombed in my eyes like I'm gonna
continue going there but nobody really
bombed in my eyes because I know what
the feeling is at that level
I know what the feeling isn't that low
it's [ __ ] horrible right it would be
much rather be at the Comedy Store at
The Improv at the Laugh Factory there
had a [ __ ] place next to a 7-eleven
across the police station yeah you can't
even smoke enjoy that side doesn't say
like so and it's a beautiful [ __ ]
place I loved the place next to a sushi
place you're gonna have sushi and going
then through comedy shouldn't leave sign
your name go eat sushi it's perfect but
it's like a real like you know what bro
took me back to where I used to be like
I went home last night I couldn't sleep
you know why cuz I started watching old
[ __ ] stand-up from what inspired me
to be those guys I got you going me so I
puts Kennison on I put egg I put and
Iran I put on go Hicks I put on [ __ ]
somebody else I watched last night Lenny
Clarke and watched a little while and
dog it lights your fire it takes you
back to where those guys were right so
in those days yeah I was bobbing like a
[ __ ] I was at that level in New
York did you all please
I was a Babak all places before I got
the salim I was coming to bomb the place
what was your act consistent back then
[ __ ] horror yeah
total heart how long did you go up for
seven minutes was it bad yes
thinking they kept you going
desperation yeah nothing else I knew
that if I didn't keep doing it I would
fall apart for sure like this was it
this was bombed like a bunch of times oh
my god from I bombed from 91 to about
ninety three and a half so what changed
when did you find one that is when did
it change for you I'm like what happened
it changed like in 94 and then it
evolved again like in 95
then by 97 I was on to something
they just started feel like he was on
something but I wasn't ready for nothing
I was on to something but I wasn't ready
for nothing but he wasn't ready there
was no way
I had a polished ten minutes if I had to
I didn't know what I was saying did
anybody talk to you to anybody like you
know guys other guys you respected maybe
no because the stage presence of the
energy was always there when I was there
so that substituted everything else not
overpowered everything else
it hit the weaknesses which was what the
writing doing the the act was from the
heart right that was good that was
generally act was from right so people
like that about you it was so funny I
watched a clip from do you have any
footage of you like early no it's not
just one person who's got my footage I'm
not to see early John it's me him and
Carlos Mencia and I'm the host of the
show and it was just god-awful I had to
do five minutes
there's probably were probably always
genuine you know I think that I'll never
forget the first time I wish that's what
I like about you yeah I took a class and
the guy said to me you're onto something
your stage presence is [ __ ] great for
that level like you're really onto
something I know who you are when you
walk up on stage I didn't know what the
[ __ ] he was talking about right
I was so desperate by 94 that I was like
I was prepared to do the journey like I
was ready to be that guy in a car that
just traveled in between five states and
did comedy and broken down bars I didn't
want nobody calling me don't reach out
it isn't like a return your calls I just
wanted to come in left all that said I
was so heartbroken I was so uh you know
at that point that this is all I wanted
to do and also handle up and see how I
was a stripper oh man next funeral I'm
up there for a year and a half and also
I'm living in a [ __ ] CA another
stripper a living in a [ __ ] RV on
Fairfax Boulevard and between sunset and
Hollywood Boulevard did you know that
the first three nights I lived here I
lived in RV in between sunset and
Hollywood Boulevard where there's a you
know anyway right there on that corner
facing towards Hollywood Boulevard will
you make a [ __ ] left to go onto
Laurel Canyon we were parked right there
gee the first three minutes take showers
and then get dressed and go to the comic
store we had the truck in the car parked
behind it on a [ __ ] trailer like you
trolled the [ __ ] trailer hey we told
the car behind this one oh we had the
same experience in San Francisco I was
doing comedy I stopped to do comedy and
she went to park the RV and she's
driving the RV and then she's going down
the block I see a two back fall off your
RV
fall off the RV and the RV falls on its
back and she's just
with the [ __ ] car oh my god
oh my god is right why'd you wind up in
Siena I went to Mission listen listen
this is [ __ ] up one of my men thism
Denver's name was Todd Jordan a very
dear friend I still loved the death a
great [ __ ] writer and I used to look
at his resume every night he had just
one 1987 HBO's comic of the year
this kid was somebody he was in People
magazine as the top 25 people to watch
under 25 I mean it was [ __ ] amazing
amazing writer just uh he just fell in
love and enter into the corporate job as
a comic for a phone company a sudden
they paid a great money and that's what
he chose to do he would write for comics
long distance like Dennis Miller at that
time and stuff away the TV show yeah but
he mentioned me then and I would look at
his resume and dream of the clubs he
played at and he had this Club in
Detroit Michigan called Joey's that was
it
Joey's comedy club and at that time they
were in Livonia Belleville and wherever
the [ __ ] I went there was three clubs
and we were talking one day oh [ __ ] this
what happened he had a weekend in the
Bahamas to be a comic and he asked me to
open front and I was supposed to meet
him in Florida and after his show in
Florida Saturday night he had a pen
decided to see how to get rushed to the
hospital and then I take his appendix
out for the weekend and the Bahamas got
canceled I couldn't go without it so I
was [ __ ] so he goes how can I make it
up to you and I hope I don't worry about
he goes no no I want to make it up to
you he goes pick a club and I'll get you
in now making a phone call get you in
there out of all the clubs
I picked [ __ ] Joey's in Detroit a
suburb of Detroit and I [ __ ] I'm so
excited this is my second comedy club I
was already working in Baltimore I go to
[ __ ] Detroit if I leave from Colorado
Nick between me and you no lie I had 30
bucks I had maybe 20 in quarters and in
those days all I would eat was veggie
and cheese sandwiches on white from
Subway I would take a sixth-century one
for breakfast
and take the other six 6-inch and he one
for lunch and then for dinner
whatever happened to happen that would
go into a supermarket his shoplift
salami I was a [ __ ] Savage and I went
to [ __ ] Detroit and I walked into the
pizza place where the guy was a
manager's name was at velasca you
remember this [ __ ] this is 1995 May of
1995 and I tell this pizza guy hey man
I'm Joey Diaz on the feature act this
ring goes well she goes boom you feel
[ __ ] you
I don't Joey Diaz dog on the feet check
this week come on you better you know
I'm I'm like come on man there's a hell
of a run it's Wednesday night [ __ ]
you're not supposed to be until Thursday
well what's wrong you thought about you
know start Wednesday night I go is there
a hotel yeah
there's dinner
not to let your own urine have a good
night I was like god damn Wow
and I [ __ ] all drove few blocks and I
saw like a Holiday Inn had a big parking
lot and I went in and I took my blanket
I was prepared I was asleep and they had
like a joint and a half way asleep in
the car in the car in the parking lot of
a holiday and then if you're slick in
those days I was so much on the road
where I figured out Wow
in the mornings you hung up by the back
door at a hotel and you may believe you
were smoking yeah and if you had like a
little travel bag when somebody walked
out you take it in and go to the gym
area this was you prayed that the gym
area and there was always like a
bathroom in the back you go in the
bathroom and freshen up there was always
scams on the road you always figured out
there was always a [ __ ] hotel girl
you knew who would [ __ ] let you go in
the back and [ __ ] feed your dog and
[ __ ] wash your face and call me and
take a shower in the sink
geez there's always that [ __ ] on garage
95 living in the backyard of a [ __ ]
hotel my friend I was doing NYPD Blue
then my god and you were like a doctor
parking lot in the parking lot it's hard
that he could be paged me back and he
goes listen do you have a suit I go yes
he goes you're opening up for Tony
Bennett at the restaurant tonight go to
the [ __ ] hotel and check yourself in
Tony Bennett hey Tony Bennett would do a
show at the Fox Theater and then they
would go to Joey's and go upstairs
downstairs to the eat right after the
show and then for the family and a few
friends he would sing two or three
little song I can't cement and they see
I Tony and people go crazy oh and you
would open food they would say do like
ten minutes be tasteful and I was
horrible
you were bad I need a bag of dicks dawg
really oh I would back that a hotel room
alone was cried but it was too late
already so I got up Thursday morning
got the free breakfast at the hotel
thank God
you wait whatever they had whatever they
had was good enough how we eat whatever
you know you got pancakes I'll take ten
of them you got [ __ ] powdered eggs I
eat the eggs white bread rye bread idea
and you would try to sneak if Elena like
you would take [ __ ] like that was how
I lived guys finally I had the sausages
whatever and he would take them up to
your room and just stay in your room and
that Thursday [ __ ] that I go to the
club I'm read through my comedy yeah my
mom stays for [ __ ] bed so the chick
Eckles me oh [ __ ] check
and I looked down I thought it was Kelly
LeBrock dog this chick was [ __ ]
beautiful the next II know we started
talking after the show
and next thing all the other comedian
comes up to me it was all you met her
she's very nice
she's got a situation tell him and she
goes right a situation
my boyfriend's told my comedy a place to
stay today I was wondering if I could
stay in your hotel room like this could
only happen to me you don't say I'm late
my king and I'm looking at this broad
like this season has to be a setup here
and I go sure I got two beds whatever
you want on the walk for the hotel he
was saying oh listen you know the salmon
drew
yeah I'm gonna tack in the middle of the
night and she's [ __ ] giggle if she
thought was [ __ ] around with and the
whole night we were in separate beds but
I kept tortured like come on you little
paste it's just you and me
oh yeah for the next day she actually
woke up and she goes you want that page
you gotta hurt it give me a two hour
ride I'll give you a little taste of
something and I said I'll be a down
payment right now you had the second
Sevilla main going on she trying a bone
though she drove naked
she told you she got naked as I drove I
know and I would tell her what to do
play with your monkey little bit stretch
of that stretches out my confession yeah
Danny why are you trying them for you
scratch it and put it but mine oh let me
slip it off your fingers like an animal
did you get hardly a job I busted up my
pants let's just ease you just fall
apart
you can't even break again you keep
hoping the deer don't run out there cuz
you can't put the brake cuz your left
leg what [ __ ] stuck she's nude
language right oh my god it was if I
couldn't believe was how my god and fed
been warming up to that in a day or at
night
this is [ __ ] the next morning we had
to check out load no I was still doing
comedy that Friday night so that day I
drove all the way up there and there was
drama there was drama she couldn't get
into a house so I had to help her break
in through the back then she got her
clothes but the boyfriend stole her
house her car keys and her wallet so she
still had no place to go
oh so now she was too upset to sue hell
I mean how can you make a chick that's
crying
so come on being holy or we could do
this in a thing oh she was beautiful big
Bush she was bad that time I hadn't seen
yes you have a bush so finally she goes
do you mind if I come back with all
towers sure can I come back to the hotel
you know I'm gonna leave you out in the
street
besides you owe me a piece ass you ain't
going nowhere so the debt is paid you
don't say and she came back to the hotel
me you know what probably became the
friends and [ __ ]
so we should write a book Sydney your
boyfriend got called the hotel all night
where the [ __ ] is she she belongs to me
I'm gonna come down then she told me the
whole story she was 25 and she was away
he was 51
she was [ __ ] him because he put it
through college ah she tried to break up
with him died he was a sugar daddy said
anguish so that's why he stole the car
the car belong to the mother oh man it
was the mother's name for now she was
busted so she stayed Friday in the hotel
on Saturday and then Sunday on the way
home I dropped her off for the house by
that time I had given it to wade through
so kala minx disturb the sukkah let me
see a little taste
and I will you know what happened bro
what happens after you get divorced like
I got divorced I was brokenhearted and I
had met some women you know but she was
the closest I met to somebody I could
hook up with and I overlooked the
stripping and the sugar daddy because
she had great [ __ ] and as a man
sometimes you overlook everything even
though you know it's gonna be dangerous
but you tell yourself you're gonna do it
differently and she's not gonna suck
nobody else's dick and even though
you're a seasoned man right you know
she's a professional dick sucker she
strips already [ __ ] you you've known her
for three days and you already know
she's a [ __ ] nude stripper in a
college town and she had a sugar daddy
for four years during college and this
guy was no [ __ ] prince matchabelli
right you know he was a horror show
that's why he was paying a 21 year old
girl to Blom sure it was a [ __ ]
horror show and she was telling me Wow
and you know by that time I thought I
was a seasoned man I had never heard
those things I was in [ __ ] shot when
she told me that [ __ ] yeah Wow it was
crazy but I still fell in love
he told Dogg I dropped her off in
Lansing Michigan and I drove all the way
back to Boulder Colorado I wasn't home
two days and she called and said
I'm coming the bold of the same forget
about that I fell in love she had there
was an opening in my heart she just
slept right in I didn't care for [ __ ]
was dirty I think if she had VD she was
beautiful when she was gonna be mine or
at least I thought it took her maybe 60
days to start [ __ ] being an animal
yet right I ended up in jail it was a
[ __ ] Horror Show but boy he is with
this [ __ ] crazy chick yeah yeah we
know we just spoke the other day for New
Year's she called me on the back Jesus
listen we remain friends things happen
in your life yeah well she's the reason
why I got that way she's the one that
was some connection if you still talk
you know maybe you guys actually listen
we broke up here like after six months
and we knew it was gonna it was at the
end we ended up fist fighting to the
death
I'm [ __ ] sunset and [ __ ] God
knowing that she had the base of the
head of salami in my ass that day yeah
yeah so I thank God I in the prison
thank God she didn't maced me in the
eyes I ever look like [ __ ] Jim
Jones's cousin you think that garlic we
remain good friends
oh she even said to me she came to see
me this last time brought her boyfriend
and her kids I should look today you
know what bro you met her did I came to
her settle Longest Yard she came to the
same and she had the baby
remember those [ __ ] deck that was
2004 so the kids 13 though she brought
him to the [ __ ] my show in Tampa they
came to the hotel I talked to him for a
little while only short it's been a
while that's a long so much happened
during the long as yard it was so
exciting it's a lot of it's a blur now
but it was not going on during a longer
shot you know join my friend my dear
friend joyful idol called
yesterday because I have him here from
the different Christmas I called you
because I called you to hurt Jovi it
happens he left Oakland here dad took
the TV in the middle of it and The
Longest Yard was starting I lost a whole
[ __ ] thing
and he goes I gotta ask you something
how much [ __ ] fun did you have
shooting it the question comes up I'm
small I'm supposed to go Steve what have
his podcast and I called them and I set
it up and I had a cancel because the
baby got something to happen with the
school and I was supposed to reschedule
it but the holidays were covered and we
discuss what we want to talk about and
he goes listen to me come on I've had
some other guys come on I rather you
know talk about too long and sharing or
no we have to talk about that night
you knocked on my door and [ __ ]
wanted the booze from inside my [ __ ]
refrigerator because they have a Steve
Howe Austin Oh Steve Austin that little
crew you'll know it
yes we'll rest losers [ __ ] yeah they
were drinking so much that first day
locked up the bar they're a crazy little
Hindu guy that you say oh this is the
case no oh my is this [ __ ] I the movie
the big [ __ ] Hindu no not the big
bald on hold on let me tell the story
cuz alright what's the big guys name
Holly Pinelli
well dolly because he was whatever they
gave him like this [ __ ] assistant and
he was this little Hindu guy that
between you and me if I had a bet a
hundred bucks I said they got bared it
better than the other side I honestly
thought that he was a hundred percent
gay if you came to me and said to me
listen your little sister has to sit
with somebody for an hour I would
definitely leave him with that person so
true The Longest Yard we're talking to
this [ __ ] broad on the set blah blah
blah blah blah
one things let's to another she's
talking to me lo Bowen and Nick a lot a
lot a lot a lot and she's definitely
talking to Nick and she's talking to me
and we all become friends
so the chick was like a cosmics masseuse
or something like that so [ __ ] she
[Music]
yes no this I wanna listen again ladies
and gentlemen ladies if I got a
yardstick I'm betting the guy is a
hundred percent gay but I guess he told
the chick I'll Drive you but you gotta
come up to my room first
he pulled the harvey he said you gotta
come up to the hotel room first
yes she was a cute girl but you know
he's a valley girl
yes yeah some chick yeah I knew the girl
that I know that but you know sayin yeah
so I'm trying to you know so the funny
thing is that like I said we're all the
same hotel so something happens that
she's gonna give him a massage next
Charlie gonna get rid of them Nick's
trying to be a nice guy and girly
here's 50 bucks do us a favor she's
looking for a ride to the whole time I
can't do it
you can't no to the heart to the airport
she was leaving town and some he lured
her into the room right and what happens
next
oh my god oh my god go ahead drop it up
so next thing you know I don't know
nothing I go back to my room I'm in love
with the movie man on fire I'm already
into the hotel too many times I'm
already into the hotel fifteen hundred
and ten dollar [ __ ] movies every time
I got that movie he was ten dollars I
would pay my bill every week it was $80
in [ __ ]
man on fires and those [ __ ]
kept charging me I hope he loved all
burns down I don't know what happens but
I got a call 10 minutes later from
dictator Lina's Joey have you seen the
[ __ ] in duty Yes Mother I know what
he's talking about you know we were all
together yeah I saw would Timothy goes
yeah he took the chick up to his room
but then he told them he was a masseuse
he was a Hindu masseuse right and next
thing that he's got a trouble and he
went into a trance or something yeah
he's totally getting creepy get me a
[ __ ] crazy hands trying to go up her
ass and and and the girl [ __ ] was you
know she was petrified oh I felt bad
because I was like I thought this guy
was innocent oh we thought I told he was
dog I'm telling you if I had to give you
know how it ended but it wasn't that
wasn't good she ran she didn't call the
cops I didn't call the cops he was
[ __ ] and think I had a scolding like
yeah you said so I think I said you saw
me turn [ __ ] he was awful this is what I
was like I had a [ __ ] tell a Hindu
you know listen something went down yeah
like so overboard you know he was
supposed to behave instead he didn't
behave so he went bananas he went funny
playing all of us he played like the
effeminate guy that was very peaceful he
wasn't and very like oh my god I'm here
helping him right meanwhile [ __ ]
Abdul he had just come to the states he
had never seen a white woman before he
was seven four four he was seven four
four with a two-foot dick he was getting
high odds on the field see those white
chicks that were just the old women like
he was the old white woman out on the
Indian dude he was eating twenties how
many eggs would they send him up to his
room for breakfast alive god this
[ __ ] guy he was a giant it's a
[ __ ] giant that's right you just
refreshed my memory but there's more to
it now you ready
guy we will laugh our asses off before
his [ __ ] he was sweating miss he was
dripping wings when we finally found
them he was a guy a little sad she was
like a [ __ ] trying to put his
hands up my ass and everything I was
like oh my thought he was a nice guy you
know I'd be quick than there's something
happened did he quit he got replaced yes
nothing happened
yeah something what he wasn't he wasn't
innocent right at the end he had to go
back to India his dad was sick overnight
so something would down I do remember
that that was a funny yeah that was a
funny little [ __ ] story
I figured I picked on him because he
looked like an innocent guy said all
right then he's a nice guy he won't do
any harm you know I never ever ever went
to Albuquerque with those guys
Albuquerque yeah I only went there those
guys were all on Wednesday night there
only one day I went to did another
project another movie but I never went
out but I just stayed in I love Santa Fe
[ __ ] loved it that was a great place
it's just I didn't I didn't want to
leave when it you know like the LA part
of the movie was okay Santa Fe was just
a blast was a brat party everything bad
boy he was I got drunk man and a fight
with the old lady I was I walked away
and remember I came back I was I took
too long and then some guy was sitting
next door and I [ __ ] screamed at the
guy guy ran away he worked in the hotel
he was just sitting there innocently he
put his hand out like that the [ __ ] out
here
I gotta think of my funniest memory
Isaac like if somebody said to me give
me your funniest day of the so long as
yard it's definitely going into my room
and definitely having two ounces a weed
in my [ __ ]
and I will roll up weed with my football
uniform of the tattoos I didn't realize
so many people were smoking pot my god
Michael it's a Sony whens Goldberg would
rip the door off the hinges I would lose
my mind by myself in that trip because I
could feel him I could hear him yelling
about something and then the door coming
off the hinges and him throwing it out
into the [ __ ] little pathway with a
golf course she could ride back and
forth to pick up the plays in the [ __ ]
hey it was a blast it really was it was
a magical I don't know just the time we
had was one of those projects where you
just you'll never forget and they played
it all the time it's amazing they
[ __ ] play a play I cannot believe
like you know it it's a shame they
couldn't have made another movie out of
it because it's got such an audience I
saw Ervin and at the fight McGregor
fight picked me up in the air he had me
in a bear hug for my five minutes man it
was it was a great time great time you
know every once in a while like I put on
sons anarchy I come home and die and I
just want to decompress you know yeah
and I'll put on those episodes when Lobo
is on that I don't know what season is
Lobos Abbas fiamma's on three or four
episodes this little son's Aniki and
they kill them off they chop his [ __ ]
head off this [ __ ] but every time I see
those episodes I remember how nice of a
time you'll be in him what happens yeah
three of us because you have you know
listen man whoever those guys were fine
but they were all like their own thing
you were scared of Romanowski the
[ __ ] wrestlers you had a [ __ ] have
a liver and a half to drink with those
animals right you know you had Adam and
his buddies yeah they weren't gonna
fight you upstairs no then you had the
one and only Tracy Morgan who once they
realized his [ __ ] torment they shot
him out as quickly as
[ __ ] impossible gone and got him on a
plane the [ __ ] out of there
yeah that's the way and somebody once
told me they don't listen Joe if I ever
get y'all on this show
my goal is to shoot you up before
anybody even shows up I don't want
nobody to see ya I don't want nobody
seeing on the [ __ ] show I just want
you to go off and I thought about think
oh that's how you shoot somebody who is
little [ __ ] up I [ __ ] around
you know he's [ __ ] up you know what he
makes six o'clock wet sixes I shoot him
by seven o'clock if he could make six
o'clock tip top Magoo on time he's not
drunk right yeah he does the other time
okay shoot him on at seven let's shoot a
lot till 10:00 don't shoot the stars
until he leaves
why get them upset yeah cuz the guy's a
powerhouse
he's the stars come in they see him and
they go why is he here he's too funny
for the show only a few listen if you
watch the pilot of 30 rock this showed
he was on with the white chick what's
her name Lee fan Tina Fey she's
brilliant for putting him on that not
too many people want to put Tracy Morgan
on there [ __ ] Michelle well he's at town
she hit it out of the park and if he
wants to pilot she has to talk to him
into the show while he's in a strip club
which is the funniest scene ever he's
like yeah I'll let you talk to me I'm on
my way to the club and he goes into a
strip club and she's sitting there with
these naked work and she's trying to
talk him into [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
it is
it's brilliant [ __ ] because they got him
I guarantee Tina Fey they want him
around all that right I guarantee she
get him in get him out coming you know
he's not gonna get crazy
you know I remember Adam used to like
you know you could see Adam liked him
yes well he liked but yet he didn't want
to let him go off he he didn't wanna he
wanted to keep him a little under
control
Adam was that you know Adam was uh he
was a lot of fun on that movie he was he
was a he was I mean I remember him
always being a pretty good mode in that
movie he was you know he he was the
ringleader but he kept everybody
everybody happy I mean
seemed very happy in them when he was
doing all those guys being around that
there was so much to be around but I
like I said I was with you
Lobo I mean thank God I didn't you
couldn't get too involved with there was
too much to that Holy Face on brother I
don't want to have no you know plus that
was yeah I was I was I was [ __ ]
focused I was well into the Seattle she
was 97 and his movies were coming out
and they were hitting that dear friends
who were into him and I went to the
house love Watson I don't know I don't
know I can't deal with this [ __ ] this is
terrible
and these past and I boycotted him my
mother
it wasn't my type of humor right
everything changed the mobile I shook
his head the first time I felt so guilty
with my sauce yeah nose well cuz he had
preconceptions about him I had
tremendous Robbie said this is this
guy's not I think I had said the same
cat when I walked out of that car and he
picked up my [ __ ] luggage with
flip-flops on on a pair of shorts and a
t-shirt and walked me up the stairs and
told me about what was about to happen
and it's great to have you Norma boy you
all packed you ready the girls class all
the way yeah yeah yeah let's go he took
us into that room yep and we did the
table read papers went for the table
open the door he was so we sat there
there was food in the back I remember
sitting in between Burt Reynolds who at
the end that team yeah I was all the way
the backwards
sorry warriors come out to play John
Bowers with him good act
I was with Mike because I know Michael
Jarvan for the best dance wart show
okay in fact there's a tape of Lee
roasting turbo going off really on that
whatever channel that was on Fox Sports
Ward yeah there's a doesn't take me
somewhere
I auditioned for that yeah which one
best damn sports yeah oh please
got hit in the [ __ ] kneecap by Jim
Lampley swinging a bat that was the
audition audition he was swinging a bat
talking about the movie 61 and took a
full swing and snare
me right my [ __ ] knee cap and I just
had pneumonia I think I was in shock and
Deacon Jones everybody was in shock
because you all right kid everybody
stopped and I just I was like I didn't
feel well and I said I just want to get
out of here
he smashed me in the knee he swung he
doesn't realize he was sitting so close
to me I screamed right on the center
it's going crazy crazy I should have
[ __ ] laid down in soot Fox I should
have [ __ ] played dead but I was just
like getting me a TA get me out of here
I was coming out of some illness and I
just was like I don't know I just I
couldn't even speak producers were like
egg talk talk and I was like I just
didn't want to be there I just did the
auditions I wanted to get out of the
house I had been sick and all this [ __ ]
but getting back to the longest show I
did Adam was great man you go - my
mother had a heart attack and I'm sorry
nicer now did you go to New Mexico right
for the table where he was I went pretty
soon and that's where my mom had the
heart attack and then I had to go back
and then and then he said yeah go ahead
don't worry and sent my mother I met you
on the van ride on the way back as well
we got kind of that we met you were
headed back to her for your Mother's Day
we had just gotten there
we just got there we had just gone I
went out for a pass and and the ball I
stole my finger to this day it never
healed some guy threw me a pass and it
jammed if I get through a [ __ ] 100
miles an hour pass and my finger never
[ __ ] healed right unbelievable then I
almost broke my foot when I fell off Bob
sack if you remember I did half the
movie with like a broken foot you
remember I hurt my foot that's right I
fell off the [ __ ] thing I was
supposed to do that mud scene with Adam
that was in the original movie and I
couldn't do to see me we had to do that
mess hall scene because in the original
movie they have a fight in the swamps in
Israel shops yeah then you put mother of
his name put more in his pants he puts
butt and that [ __ ] scene we could not
do because I couldn't
I could only limp I wasn't I was in
agony I was coming to work every day
with the [ __ ] on the crutches that
fell off his back and I had a bone
contusion on my heel and I couldn't do
it at they were like this kid can't do
the fight I couldn't even run through
the tyres some 12
I can do this right if you look at it as
a tall guy that means good double yeah
oh yeah one of the doubles and then I
come out of the tire but uh now Adam was
great he was just he was he was like way
different than you would have ever
thought you know I had heard guys that
worked with him that my brother worked
with him and he said he's a great guy
and other guys said he's really a good
guy and you know and the nice thing
about him was he let people shine he did
you know if he knew you were funny he
passed you the ball he treated a ball he
gave you a chamois knee he gave me a
legitimate shot that that part was
nothing on paper and then it became like
it became like a part it became
something right after the first scene
with me and you with a half a meatball
he came over to me you [ __ ] came over
to me I had the haircut and he goes dude
you're [ __ ] funny dude you're funny
dude and I was just you know I was just
going there trying to create a character
I wasn't thinking about anything because
it's a million you that was a funny
scene you know tree out you know you're
doing a tree out and I come over there
you have for me ball whatever I said
that was my first day yeah I was like
that was my first real day but I was
down there for a week oh you weren't I
would wake up and I'd be in the hotel
room huh I go downstairs eat breakfast
go back up smoke a joint and then about
to I would be hungry
and I called the set and they said the
shuttle over to get me and drive me to a
set I go over there shake a few hands
hang out with Ivan get some chicken
breasts or whatever the [ __ ] they were
that was great you got all you can go
anything go back down I was ready
give me a shuttle back ride to the hotel
and then we gonna box to go the big fat
dude would give you a box of chicken and
whatever you owe me and you went back to
you mean and you watch TV and nobody but
I did that's the first five you can't
understand we got treated like kings you
don't get treated like that today on out
of the movies you know fed you know I
mean no but not like that that was Adam
treated everybody great that was first
class all the way I mean it was really
really good and gave you a call I think
I had a car on a car DM it was fun when
I got there I had a
I can I have a pack of cigarettes I had
[ __ ] great joints and a half and I
don't know what I had for money I had
nothing and I didn't know what I was
going to do next and what we landed hey
I love that when they hands you down
below oh my god you know an angel eyes I
got no reason to go see you
[ __ ]
I borrowed I think I paid we one of the
Tuesday and I did comedy that Monday
night and whatever cash I had whenever
extra my wife had mean you were waiting
for the residuals oh [ __ ] we will
[ __ ] talk and planning who would like
you were like Nikki I am wait for the
[ __ ] oh I had it on paper yeah you doing
the math I figured was solving me up oh
you had me on the [ __ ] go I was I
couldn't wait and I think it was like
the second or the third that was like
the big check you know I think the first
one might have been a little small then
I was like am i where's this
[ __ ] Coco said it's gonna be
big and their way was good it was good
it was tremendous I was a big movie
[ __ ] big movie I mean it was really a
it was it was it was a it was a blast I
have to say it was special you know the
whole experience it was good I mean I
knew it was gonna be I knew it was gonna
be something both premieres were good
the New York premiere was great that was
a good when I was got into it with a
whole [ __ ] and want to get into it we
had a blast there blast in LA the LA one
we buy with Jimmy Kimmel was shoots yeah
they rented that out and put them into a
football yeah my god Rachel turf and it
was all balls this grain was football at
our tables with our names raisi [ __ ]
baseball cards we all had our own cards
I'll never forget that I got the cocaine
delivered to the fence
hey Dad the kids pulled up and I walk by
his home I'll be right back
and I walk straight through the fence
during the premiere gave the guy the 60
bucks they gave me to grab and nobody
saw anything
and then walk back to his back you told
me you had some pictures for me once
from the New York one you like I got
some pictures for you but I never got
those pictures you said I got some pills
[ __ ] wild lights from reverb when I
was a good night buys was the buys a Boz
was cool everybody was really everybody
was cool I mean you know everybody was
you know yeah she's so good [ __ ] the
wall we should tell the people the
recipe for the sauce
oh my source why it's say you know Vicki
did it again you don't saying knocked it
out of the park with the sausage with
the pork you know you get the cut up the
garlic brown the garlic put the meat in
and you put your fresh basil your
oregano a little parsley little grated
cheese a little sugar a little wine and
then he put it on a nice little low
flame cook the meat and baboon but it's
the hand you understand you like that
Joe Nikki red sauce it's coming this
year I know I promised oh you guys I'm
getting it out there it's been a while
but it's gonna be a I don't know tonight
he got the real thing yeah he loves it I
wanted you to taste the real thing
because the last time you love the JA
sauce and the joe sauce was [ __ ] good
sausage after six o'clock he knows a
good sausages no I got them from a fresh
from a butcher those are no [ __ ]
sausages you can't bite I was in Trader
Joe's
thattaboy this gravy when they said no I
call it sauce some Italians call it
gravy but you know to me I don't like to
say gravy because this sounds like
[ __ ] yeah you know white people say
that stuff I know some Italians know it
yeah [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] soy sauce you want to call it
gravy go ahead some people want to make
a guy I call it so I'll do a [ __ ]
the red sauce is what I always call it
you know let's just even have the funny
[ __ ] tomorrow be even better
speaking eat this show like I told you
the beginning I always get great
sponsors I loved with all my heart I
have a great time with him I don't mind
talking about it
but one of my favorites that's why they
stuck around and I wanted to stick
around with blue apron and like I told
you in the beginning blue apron
is the leading milk it delivery service
in the US and what many people know what
we do many don't know about what type of
meals eat when you cook with blue apron
you're not just having burgers for
dinner you're making short rib burgers
with a happy cheddar sauce on a pretzel
bun crispy shallots and the green beans
and mashed potatoes all in under 45
minutes and without a trip to the
grocery store are you following me
here's the beauty of our blue apron all
right blue apron delivers fresh pre
proportion ingredients and step-by-step
recipes right to your door that can be
cooked and on the 45 minutes the menu
changes every week based on what's the
season and is designed by blue apron
with the in-house skill and every team
blue apron offers 12 new recipes each
week and customers can pick two three or
four recipes based on what best fits
their schedule ploy percent only non GMO
ingredients and meat with no added
hormones all right blue apron is taken
carry because I'll tell you what listen
for this week's menu this month's menu
Steak Diane with mushroom pan sauce and
mashed potatoes do you know how to make
that no you know what blue apron you'll
learn how to make that general towels
chicken with bok choy and jasmine rice
do you know how to make that no you know
when you know how to make that whole
approved Mexican spice barramundi with
kale sweet potato and avocado salad you
gotta make that meal do you know how to
make a prove Tiger achi chicken lettuce
cup Slavik ah no no you don't you're
gonna make those things that's what blue
apron like I said we have the team of
professional
putting in a lot of care to creating
recipes each week all right some of the
best parts of our day happened over
dinner so we want you to share that
perspective a family that cooks together
stays together boil is available for -
or for the family plan but it all starts
right here blue apron is taking care of
the church - what's happening now
they're gonna help you with the first
three meals it turns out of value with
your first order if you visit blue apron
coms last show again blue apron dot-com
/ Joey like I said this week's menu oh
my god Steak Diane with the mushroom pan
sauce let's get to it you understand me
and you get $30 off with free shipping
at blue apron coms last Joey blue apron
a better way to cook this shows also
brought to you by honey you like Joey
why is your mind always ticking you know
why alpha brain that's why I can tell
you it's tarifa I call my little alpha
brain cycles from time to time
I'm tip-top Magoo I get my six hours
sleep who's gonna stop me let me tell
you why I love alpha brain and why I
love on it because they back what they
sell if it don't work for you you send
them back and they give you your money
back money you don't have to send the
product back not to mention all the
other great products they have my shroom
takes portrait tech immune the the hemp
horse protein milkshakes are [ __ ]
delicious the acai vanilla or the cocoa
whatever the [ __ ] you choose calm right
now press in church Pham and get ten
percent off your order
right to your [ __ ] house you
understand me also you're thinking about
jiu-jitsu you're thinking about mats
you're thinking about rash guards do me
a favor go to Fuji sports.com right now
look at the great selection they have
your life's impressed in church help us
out get 15% off your order right now
today I want to thank my brother Nick
the Toro for making this awful if I want
to apologize to him about asking and I
didn't want a bunch of kids in the
studio because I didn't know these
children
they wanna get in trouble if my deepest
apologies I want you to extend my
apologies I'm a gentleman but I don't
want to get no children and problems and
I get problems and you get problems back
and one of the cover of THC on set and
if you don't think it'll get work now
think of what happens when you rank the
cover th TMZ for hanging out with kids
and straight America's know cuz they
were tricking red wine that's all I need
to see if the kids weren't drinking they
come in here there's three bunks we go
to jail me and you yeah hundred 20 20 20
to the life no-parole
anyway I want to thank you guys again
don't forget two weeks from now Austin
Texas like a [ __ ] the 18th to
the 20th least cuddled with me go to cap
city calm down for tickets I want to
thank my brother Nick tutorial for a
marathon podcast Lisa at has to him cook
you so well have a great week stay black
and see you Monday morning thank you
buddy
[Music]